[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
oh my goodness Knight d8 whoa Bishop
F7 oh no
no no
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Norway land of fjords Majestic mountains
Cliffs and waterfalls in addition to
stunning geography Norway is home to the
greatest chess player who has ever lived
Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlton once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long-time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and shakuria Mami
yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
hello and welcome to the penultimate day
of Norway chess where the Americans
Fabiana caruana and Hikari Nakamura
dominate the race for the crown there
are however four other contenders all
vying for a very remote chance of Glory
who managed to use the rest day to
refuel their energy and who is feeling
the fatigue we'll find out today so stay
tuned I'm your host International Marcy
Ivanka houska and as always it's been a
wonderful pleasure to be calling all the
action alongside the legendary
Grandmaster Judy poga and the amazing
Grandmaster and commentator David Howell
oh guys it's been an eventful tournament
and on Tuesday we saw that there were
two clear contenders for first place so
Fabiana caruana is in the lead do you
think Judah he will maintain his
Advantage well his lead
well it's one thing that he has a
two-point lead in the tournament of
course this is fantastic two to go but I
would still probably bet on him that
he's able to keep his lead because he
plays extremely well and I believe he's
the most stable player in the tournament
and Hikaru is chasing down Fabiana
Corona two-point deficit can Hikari
catch up well it's good news for Hikaru
Nakamura and it's bad news for Hikaru
Nakamura if Hikaru wins he's right there
he takes it to the final day where he'll
get a shot he plays against Fabiano with
the white pieces the bad news for him if
he doesn't win today then it's all in
fabiana's hands Fabiano can actually
wrap up the tournament with a round to
spare oh oh well let's have a recap of
Tuesday's results remember yesterday was
a free day and it was a very eventful
day on Tuesday first of all Fabiana
carrona lost his Armageddon game against
kukash and for Magnus Carlson it was a
tale of the woes continuing as he failed
to convert a dominating position against
alireza faruja and this means he has now
dropped out of contention for first
place and due date
what were your highlights of that day
well there are two highlights for me it
was Magnus costume versus firoza because
it was very interesting opening already
starting from move three that there are
surprising moves arised on the board so
that was a big clash with a lot of ups
and downs and great surprises and
blunders I must say but also there were
other games which were very interesting
uh so yeah and everything to play for
and for you David oh it was just all the
armageddon's uh Ivanka Fabiano of course
just the most impressive taking a very
important win uh at the end but yeah
it's just non-stop excitement here at
Norwich us and uh talking about non-stop
excitement let's have a look at the
standings now there are two players who
did leave Tuesday grinning from ear to
ear and that was Wesley so who managed
to end a drawing run and with his
classical Victory he Rockets up to third
place with ten and a half points and
they're at the top Fabiano caruana he
did have a disappointing day as he
crashed in the Armageddon game ticket
cash but he still has a two-point lead
off on with 14 and a half points and
Hikaru Nakamura he defeated Shakira
mamajarov in a really resplendent
Armageddon game it was a fiery he is two
points behind with 12 and a half points
so everything to play for
and talking about everything to play for
there is going to be a lot of fun to be
had because this is Norway chess every
day is a treat as we take a look at
today's matchups now there are a few
few match-ups that really stand out the
first one is of course chakra mamajarov
against Magnus Carlson that one is going
to be a fiery and then at the bottom we
have Fabiana caruana against Wesley so
all American matchup this is huge for
the standings Judith what else catches
your eye well those are some of the
obvious matchups which you mentioned
also Fabiano and Hikaru but I will be
also curious to see how mama jarov and
Magnus Carson will be playing it out
yeah and for me it's aleriza farusha
against Anish giri both of them have
that small tiny chance of winning the
tournament if they win both of their
remaining classical games and they both
therefore in a muscle situation will be
going for each other yeah in a must-win
situation and when it comes to Norway
chess winning is the name of the game
because Norway Charles has a very unique
fighting format a 10 player single round
robin 120 minutes for the entire game
sounds like a lot it really isn't and
this is the twist there will be a 10
second increment added after move 40 and
in the case of a draw Armageddon will
break the tie it will be a three points
awarded for a classical win and a one
and a half points for an Armageddon win
and of course it's Fighting Chess so no
draw offers before move 30 and here come
the players here we see Wesley so
getting lined up to meet Fabiana caruana
Wesley in third place and he has a tiny
chance of actually winning the
tournament if the results work his way
and by working his way he needs to
secure a classical Victory against
Fabiana with the black pieces
absolutely this is uh his way of doing
it and of course the rivals like
Nakamura and others they are very much
looking forward to this game as well
because at this point of the tournament
you don't only watch your own game but
the rivals are really checking very
heavily the other games as well
and there we can see Hikaru playing with
the black pieces he's in second place he
needs to be beat no no their back
abdisotarov and well
the track record is in hikaru's favor I
see somehow that Nakamura is very
stressed he's nervous I think he he
knows it that this is his chance he can
catch up maybe with Fabiano or at least
if he wins the arm the classical game
then tomorrow it will be in his hands
how the outcome of the tournament will
be and but I feel something that he is
he's the most nervous at this point in
this tournament yeah we can't forget
that Hikaru will have one eye on that
Carolina game because he needs to at
least match fabiana's classical result
if he needs uh if he wants to win this
tournament tomorrow if he wants to have
any shot at all so yeah he'll need to
take risks accordingly on how the games
develop
and we shouldn't forget about the fact
that also notir break is not in good
form he is in the very bottom of the
tournament he lost in a very bad game
against the Wesley so in the previous
round so when you you play against an
opponent it means who is in bad form it
can be very tricky and
yeah and there we can see gukash placing
off against the tail and uh orientari
things have just not gone tari's way and
cash has been very impressive especially
when it comes to armageddon's I think
he's won four out of his five
armageddons against some big names they
get some big names and he almost won
five out of five so close to taking down
Magnus Carson go cash with a shot but uh
here we have our leader Fabiana carwana
against his fellow American Wesley so
and Wesley needs to win today in order
to have any chance at all of winning the
tournament so of course not gonna be
easy as black but maybe it depends on
how ambitious Fabian is feeling well
this is a big question what kind of
opening we'll be standing in the on the
board just in a few minutes because
Wesley is a very solid player right he
is not the kind of guy who wants to be
going out and sharpen It Out by any
means while Fabiano
obviously had to come here today with
this clear strategy how he wants to be
playing this game is he going to be
ready to take risk he just wants to play
as if it would be round three let's say
or he is already looking very much over
to the end of the tournament he wants to
make a very solid game at the same time
it means that the pressure will be there
tomorrow
and there we see two other players who
have a very tiny chance as David
mentioned of winning the tournament they
do need to win both classical games and
these two are the only ones that I saw
actually relaxed before the game
everyone else you can really detect the
tension in their body language and here
comes Magnus
yeah Magnus uh actually one of two
players who haven't won a classical game
so far in norwichs it's the two
Norwegians Magnus Carson and ariantari
so they both need to get motoring today
uh Magnus out of the running for first
price but still of course wants to end
on a high and Fabiano against Wesley I
think we'll be pressing those clocks any
second now
but don't you think that for Magnus it
must be a torture kind of thing to still
play on the tournament when he knows
that he's not playing for the first
place it's a matter of Pride yeah as you
say you did not that much to play for
but rating points Maybe
yeah but he has such a huge lead
number two
and we're off handshake what will
fabiana's first move be it's one D4 he's
been playing all sorts of openings this
tournament and Drew that before the
broadcast we were saying Fabiano he's no
chicken he's been playing extremely
ambitious openings every round
very curious what he has in mind with
the
starting the E4
and what will
Wesley play
uh he tends to keep it solid okay
opening up with a knight
I've seen these two play Queens Gambit
accepted yeah that's what he told us
that well he plays Queens Gambit it's
easy
look so many so many lines as in the
groomfield so we are going to
see probably in himself
on the board
wow if black brings this bishop out to
B4 exactly and sure enough it does
yeah it's on the board and Fabiano plays
E3 one of the most trendy moves right
now
how will Wesley react will he Castle
will he push a pawn in the center
yeah what do you think result wise do
you think Fabiano will go all out if he
gets a chance or do you think he'll just
keep it solid knowing that he can take
it to the final day
well I think
the Benji would be which is very
difficult to keep to kill keep yourself
calm to play a healthy opening and then
if he has the chance he will go for it
but not necessarily that he wants to
create anything special but it's very
important for him not to have this
pressure on his mind about the result
that oh what will be today and tomorrow
there is a difficult day or it can be
very challenging match tomorrow so if he
can keep himself calm and focus only on
today's game that's the biggest
achievement I think for for the game
during the game not to have all these
bothering thoughts about tomorrow or the
final outcome of the tournament round by
round step by step move by move that's
the way we climb Mountain Street that's
the way that these players should be
playing
and uh what do you think of Fabiano's
opening choice
Bishop D2 it's a trendy line but not the
most thematic I would say not the most
principled idea yeah essentially white
is saying you will not double my pawns
uh if you ever take the White Knight on
C3 then white will recapture with the
bishop so it has a very solid reputation
maybe again as you say not the most kind
of principled ambitious it's not
challenging white uh challenging
Wesley's set up here uh directly but
he's saying okay white still has the
center and it's up to Black to solve
that tension and here we go kind of
transposing to a hybrid of the Queen's
Gambit declined and the nimso Indian now
Wesley sticks his claim with D5
and yeah Judith I guess this line wasn't
too uh kind of popular back when you
were playing
well yeah Bishop D2 I'm not even sure I
ever met this move over the board and I
believe it's the solid way of playing
because once you have A3 Bishop C3 bc3
and the double pawns on the C file it
can be challenging it can be interesting
white has a great position but you have
to be alert on many different things and
it can be very active but here I think
Fabiano is really taking the solid calm
way having his pieces on the right
Square playing logically
and straightforward and the principal
move on the board we do see the pawns
get captured in the center this is the
stand way of handling any type of
Queen's Gambit position when black steps
forward with a Pawn on B6 and it was
interesting a moment ago we saw someone
kind of block the camera walk past the
camera it was our fourth commentator it
was Hikaru Nakamura already showing
interest in Fabiano's game I think
that's going to be a theme today Hikaru
He Will Be watchful over this one to see
how the game unfolds knowing that he'll
have to take risks accordingly
exactly and I think this is an important
point because until this point of the
tournament I don't think any of the
player took risk accordingly what was
happening on other boards at the same
time today it is the case that the
Nakamura also knows it that if this game
the classical game will be drawn then he
will have to make a decision if he's
he's in a situation that he has to go
sharp or he goes to drawish game then he
will have to make a decision how is he
going which direction and he wants to
put all in for tomorrow that I play with
white against Fabiano and I'm going to
be winning or he says that no I have to
try it now to win in the classical
yeah and talking about hikaru's game
shall we whilst Wesley takes I think
shall we pop over and see what kind of
opening is on that board
yep so we quite stuck to the game
between Carolina and Wesley so how about
Abdul sotorov against Nakamura that one
has progressed it's around move 10. it's
not the most dramatic opening uh here or
shall we say it is a Berlin defense it
has stemmed from The Rook to E1
variation which has a reputation of
being extremely solid Judah I think this
is Abdul sator of showing after a tough
tournament as you mentioned uh that he's
happy to start solidly with white here
yes we had this position uh some
previous days ago I don't know who
played it exactly also to went back to
E2 and interesting Knight C4 very
interesting idea black definitely wants
to go D5 and develop properly
uh just because you play very solid if
you desperately want to make a draw in
this position with white it's not going
to be so simple so he I hope for him
that he has an idea in his preparation
and he knows how he's going to be
developing at the same time of course
it's a very equalish position and
generally in this system I was playing
it with white and you struggle how to
get a game something interesting and not
to simplify the pieces because Knight D2
is an obvious move but you don't want to
Simply exchange the knights because
after that it's just simply capture and
D5 and black is just doing fine
so white always has to try out some
things the thing I'm wondering is that
after Knight C4
what if B3
is there some
what is the real idea is black going to
go back with the Knight to A5 and C6
yeah the Knight can drop back to A5 back
to C6 put some pressure on the D Pawn I
guess alternatively after B3 drew that
maybe just Knight back to B6 although
the Knight is a bit silly here dominated
by the B3 Pawn well at the same time
Knight C4 I don't know if it was it was
played ever but maybe it is already a
move which uh Nakamura wants to provoke
and not they're back in the opening that
I make a move which looks suspicious or
dubious move and then you think that
you're better and you want to win
desperately this game because he's doing
badly in the tournament scoring very
little points because at this point
especially if you play against the
youngsters
then they are not sure whether okay
should I go for a very solid just make a
draw and go home and finish the
tournament as fast as possible or you
say no we have two more games to go
today I'm playing against Nakamura so
I'm going to win against him and then
you really want to show that maybe the
tournament is not the way the thing's
going for me but now finally I'm going
to show that I'm going to win this kind
of classical game right so I think
Nakamura is kind of provoking no they're
back with this move Knight C4
interestingly enough I've had a look at
the database and the database is saying
it has been played before this Knight C4
is a little bit of an excur obscure move
but it does have pedigree I mean
um Maxine fashion degrath was playing
with the white pieces against Anish giri
get this in the pro league just now and
that game ended in a draw
other names are Andrea yes Andre
yesipenko has also played this last year
ended in a draw there have been a few
black victories though
um Ballas shonka won the a game with
black using this line and uh Vladimir
kramnik also in 2019 defeated Vladimir
ferise in this line with the black
pieces yeah but there's always a
question whether they are rapid Blitz
game or classical you know
those are always a big big question when
we talk about objectively but opening
preparation because I don't see such a
great achievement for black from D6 the
Knight is moving all the way to B6 I
mean really B6 is the best Square the
Black Knight can get
well
I think yes sorry maybe I'm too critical
about this Knight C4
and interesting enough to answer your
point the game between feather save and
Vladimir kramnik was played in tasa
Steel
so it was a classical game and I guess
Black's whole night maneuver is just
designed on provoking white to play B3
and uh you both are Berlin experts I
mean how weakening is this B3 move well
I'm not so sure it's weakening but it
does prevent weight from ever pushing
forward with the D5 Pawn we should
mention that earlier in the tournament
Wesley Sue had this variation against
Nakamura you mentioned it Judy Wesley
also put his Rook on E2 and very shortly
uh Wesley put his Pawn later on D5
gaining space clumping down on Black's
position and now this has been prevented
uh pushing the pawn to D5 due to a pin
uh the A1 Rook would now be hit so he's
basically guaranteeing Nakamura that he
can kind of attain symmetry with putting
the pawn on D5 and uh yes he's gonna put
his Knight on a bit of a silly Square
maybe on B6 but if he can put the pawn
on D5
symmetry he's going to assume he's going
to bank on the fact that that might well
just be equal later on I should also
mention that it's now been almost three
and a half minutes since Noddy back
played the move B3 Nakamura finally
returns to the board three and a half
minutes surely he was in the
confessional surely he was telling us
some opening ideas and he gets back to
the board straight to the moves again
Knight B6 has landed and yeah D5
guaranteed next move well and also of
course in this opening the Petra of uh
what is it it's Berlin they are so
similar because in Metro it can also get
there
so that I mean if black wants to have a
game he has to come up with this kind of
interesting moves that you're not
exchanging the Rooks immediately with
rookie 8 you don't play what most of the
people do with Knight F5 and also there
is another idea behind it that maybe
simply Nakamura does not like the fact
if the white bone reaches to D5 because
its white has the space Advantage even
though it does not give much but in
structure of course maybe he's he wants
to have the pawn on D5 even though if
temporary the Knight on B6 stands not so
well
yep he will put this knife in a bit of a
better Square later or at least he will
hope to do that uh in the meantime we
shouldn't forget that White's Rook is on
a bit of a clumsy Square so
um yeah as you say Judith choosing a
rarer option here just to get another
back thinking uh as early as possible
looks like a decent strategy uh in on
the face of things things are roughly
balanced uh right now yeah now the
question is for white whether do white
have to play C3 let's say in order to
bring the Knight to D2 so the D4 Pawn is
not under attack and bring it to Knight
D2 Knight F3 Knight E5 possibly because
Black's plan for sure is going to be D5
or is white going to take the
opportunity and put the fiance away
after he played B3 but I would rather
have the bishop I think on F4 in a later
stage yeah that tends to be where the
bishop belongs in these structures
okay well well Hikaru actually making
his his uh ideas very clear he just
wants to establish equality and then
take it from there so this one looks
like not that much happening right now
the players will relocate their pieces
and the game will continue very
peacefully for the time being so shall
we have a look back at the bird's eye
view and take a look at the other games
and see if there is any excitement
happening
and
so
Shaq mamajarov Wesley Wesley Magnus
Carlson
that could be Brewing up to a lot of
dynamic possibilities and then we have
of course the two players with the 0.1
chance of winning alireza farouza and
Anish giri they look like they're in
some mainstream e45s
but
and uh then I'm Gonna Leave it to you
guys what do you think
I think we can go to Mama jar of Magnus
just to take a look what Magnus is up to
yeah let's go around the horn let's
check out all of the openings uh on the
island that we're seeing so far in round
eight and this one is still early days
just as uh with all of the other games
we're now 11 moves in it's been the
Queen's Gambit declined should we do a
recap how we got here yes uh just from
move one let's go for an action replay
uh we saw managerov as he always seems
to do starts this game with one D4 and
after Knight F6 we did not see the Ninja
as with the Carolina game instead like
developing the Knight to F3 and in this
position which Grisha calls the main
position black having eight or nine very
kind of logical moves here Magnus simply
went for Bishop E7 uh simple development
and after E3 struck with C5 Magnus has
had this from the white side as well in
World Championship matches uh so he
knows everything there is to know pretty
much about these variations there was a
Trader pawns forcing the black dot
squared Bishop to move device and
another Trader pawns has left black with
an isolate isolated Pawn on D5 but now
after Bishop D6 he's arguing that he's
got a slight lead in development and
later on if given the opportunity he
might even push himself with D4
uh what do we think Judith Ivanka to me
this isn't Magnus Carlson at his most
ambitious it's just Mainline stuff it's
rock solid for black but nothing more
than that
I'm surprised that we are seeing such a
solid position on this board because I
was expecting Mama jarov also to somehow
to go out with some uh some more
complicated position that that was my
idea that he would
like to make it a mess on the board and
this seems to be so solid I don't know
if white is going Bishop G3 in this this
point or is he capturing on D6
I have the opening days right of
database right in front of me and the
main move is actually to play Queen A4
uh 10 games there
Bishop takes Bishop is another option
that has been played nine times and only
once has someone ever retreated the
bishop
Queen A4 the idea is to allow the bishop
trade but on White's terms you want to
prevent black from ever breaking out in
the center as well with D4 otherwise the
symmetrical structure will ensue and
okay he goes for the kind of simple
approach Bishop takes D6 and Judy you
mentioned that uh manager of trying to
keep things simple I'm surprised that
Magnus isn't uh trying to play more
fiery chess here I know he's got black
but he's normally more provocative than
this it feels like the black uh position
here it's fine but the best you can ever
hope for is to play D4 in equalize
so I'm surprised both players seem to be
treating each other with a lot of
respect here
maybe reflected in the fact that neither
player can win the tournament now yeah I
was gonna mention that you know Magnus
had won the tournament four times
previously he can no longer win the
event now
is he just simply not motivated and just
planning to flash out some moves and
then take it to Armageddon
he's got a good track uh track record
here in the Armageddon so far this
tournament six out of six Magnus
well uh well he just played Queen F6 and
he played it instantly basically of
course Bishop G4 was not possible
because of tactics of Bishop H7 and
Knight G5
maybe we can play this out and
this is the reason why it's important
for black to cover the G5 Square
because uh yeah after Bishop G4 takes
Knight G5 and white with the takeaway
the bishop and extra Pawn so this is the
reason why Queen F6 was kind of a smart
move and of course it seems like Magnus
knows it exactly how to equalize it from
this position now the B2 Pawn is under
attack so the question whether white
goes B4 or queen D2 but next move Bishop
G4 will be very energetic for black but
I don't think black can play really for
uh for Advantage for the moment but I'm
not even sure right now how ambitious is
in this game
we see on the screen they both have nine
points they're both too far off the lead
right now so a draw yeah it would suit
both of course not a great tournament
for both so far but yeah I love magnus's
last move at least Bishop G4 on the
cards as you say just a bit annoying not
necessarily threatening too much but
Queen takes B2 the other uh annoying
move
do we see white ever been better we said
uh it feels like it should fizzle out
towards equality well I mean black has
to play in a really concrete way as Jude
has indicated and I feel like B4 is the
move
otherwise black will simply reach over
to B2 and steal it so okay and then and
then Bishop G4 is due to highlighted
completely logical and the only question
is is like can white do something like
Bishop E2 and keep that D5 Pawn alive
yeah keeping the tension here and let's
say black just defends that one I can
think the kind of battle revolves around
this D4 square if white can control it
then White's doing well but if black can
push yeah so I was thinking here in
Knight D4 to stop that D4 Pawn Advanced
and if I capture Bishops
guess you have to take with a knight and
I haven't done anything and then D4
comes anyhow I'll offer a draw Ivanka do
you accept yes but I'm not allowed to
because we have to play 30 moves
stickler for the rules you have to find
the repetition of moves yeah so this is
the kind of thing that could happen if
neither side is playing too ambitiously
but yeah let's zoom out because uh
manager if we all know him we all know
his instincts if he gets a chance to
complicate it he will take that
okay so should we check out some of the
others what do you think the end of this
game
uh I think it will be a draw and more
than one hour from here or less I think
less what oh what about you well yeah I
also have a strong feeling that this
game will not last long it's a beautiful
day here in Stavanger and uh in the city
that I live in Bergen we have this rule
that when the sun is shining you have to
drop what you're doing and you have to
go outside okay
and it was like Norwegian philosophy
you've got to follow it don't be stuck
indoors
Magnus looks ready for some sun
and maybe we can uh looking at the
bird's eye view kind of take a look at
the alireza farisha game although I can
see that kukash is heating up against
the orientare
just played a very ambitious move but
first let's go to the two players here
who can win the tournament with a bit of
luck if all the results go their way and
uh yeah alerusa
starts with the white pieces against uh
Gary here and uh you mentioned it's an
E4 E5 opening here Ivanka White's done
something slightly strange though it's
rare to see the white Bishop Phoenix on
G2 in such an opening so some kind of
small twists on what looks like an
Italian game
and do we think Judith well it seems
like I mean you could also cover a half
board but white is playing his moves and
black is playing his moves and then we
take away the card which cover and ah
you didn't play detailing you went
beyond Chen with G3 Bishop G2 it's
really it is really like that that the
black was not paying attention that
I think they have that game actually on
chess.com they have a fog of War where
you just see your squares and you just
have to guess I have this feeling here
right that I mean somehow The Bishop's
supposed to be on C4 B3 or B5 by now but
it's very interesting to have it on fear
and chat the way
what do we make of the resulting
position should we quickly do a recap to
show how we got here yeah let's see yeah
let's say let's jump in with an action
replay it's move nine now and uh this
game started with the King's Pawn
opening and G3 a move uh yeah that
doesn't often appear at top level
usually white brings the bishop out as
Judith mentioned instead we see Knight
F6 D3 and white essentially playing a
king's Indian attack type of setup but
just ignoring completely what black does
and uh here we see just very sensible
developing moves slightly interesting
for me that white kind of broke forward
in the center so soon white played D3
just three or four moves ago now white
steps into the center again with D4 and
after Bishop to A7 the question for
white is whether you can strike now
before black Gets Ready black would love
to play a move like rookie eight put
some pressure against this uh E4 Pawn
Black's Bishop extremely well placed uh
on this diagonal so you don't really
want to open things up you don't
necessarily want to lock the position
and gain space with white right now D5
Black's more than happy to set back and
actually black will have the advantage
beautiful Bishop later on this F five
push will undermine White Center so what
to do the tension seems fine for black
right now well this looks really good
for black having his Bishop on A7
instead of having it on E7 let's say he
would have been playing get the in a
passive way because yeah for now I don't
see the benefits of having the fianceato
bishop here and indeed after D5 the E7
square is free for the night so this is
something exceptionally positive for
black and now I don't know how white
wants to play maybe he wants to go
Knight A3 because for the moment Knight
D2 is not possible because the A7 Bishop
C6 Knight E5 Pawn attacking the D4 so
that would be a bone sacrifice and the
white has to develop somehow right and
the B5 square is weak so right now
instead of the bishop maybe Knight will
take occupy that square or also another
idea to go Knight C4 and put pressure
especially on the E5 Square the E5 bone
and also sometimes to the A5
um yeah I've I kind of seen that idea
done many many times but not in
conjunction with the bishop on G2 and
it's difficult to kind of
say why but it kind of feels a bit weird
for me to put the bite on C4 and the
reason why is because when I try to do
this myself is that black was always
playing Pawn takes Pawn in the center
and then breaking through a D5
that's also possible and then that's not
the only problem it can be after Knight
C4 but also possible that Knight E4 and
after rookie 4 D5
so it's uh but if I say H3 was played
which is also a very typical move when
you have a fianchetto the main idea is
to cover and take away the G4 Square
from the Knight order Bishop because
Bishop G4 was kind of a strong threat
and also in the next move maybe white
wants to play Bishop E3 and that's how
he wants to exchange later the bishop
the A7 Bishop by playing D5
uh final question just before we move on
from this game how does ferrugia intend
to meet the simple move from Rook to E8
because already there might be some
pressure against this white Pawn in the
center still hard for white to develop
well I would consider to play D5 after
rookie 8 because after rookie 8 if I go
D5 and you go Knight E7 The Rook would
be standing much better on f8 for a
later Knight H7 and F5 kind of ideas and
after Knight E7 what about playing
Bishop E3 eliminating the powerful
Bishop on A7 and after takes takes to
play C4 Knight C3 and if might can
develop that way it can be a great
position for a while just like that it
kind of feels like a king's Indian yes
yes but without the black Bishop having
on G7
it's not the king's Indian
beloved King's Indian yeah I was playing
it well and I loved it but without the
black Square Bishop even though it's
biting its uh phone on E5 but once it
opens up that's powerful did you ever
play the French defense no no no so you
didn't want to have a C8 Bishop exactly
but that barely have any opportunity to
break out you don't even have dreams of
that
in the French defense if your bishop
ever comes out you mean you just win
everything yeah but the promise it never
happens
but in King's Indian it does
I'm scared of both openings I'll just
say that so yeah this one's still early
days between farrugia and Gary uh very
very tense all pieces on the board looks
like both players are desperate to win
this one to try and win the tournament
and let's go and check out the remaining
game of the round that is between kukesh
who's actually got a chance of winning
the tournament as well and Aaron tari
the tail Ender uh certainly and we have
to give thanks to our resident
statistician who didn't fall into that
so word trap uh Thai Thai Bruce cinnamon
who Chess By Numbers who did tweet that
these were the statistics and he said
that good cash has a 0.3 chance of
winning now David and myself once
commented on a tournament where gukash
was playing and in the final day I think
ukash had a is it 0.03 chance of winning
yeah five rounds remaining he needed to
win all of his games and hope that all
the other results went his way and of
course guess he won the tournament it
was good cash
so you never know miracles do happen and
this is the position we see in front of
us I know a lot of our viewers at home
will recognize this opening instantly
because there's a bishop on F4 it's one
of the first openings one of the most
popular openings at kind of Club level
the London system but maybe let's Zoom
back and go through the first few moves
because some strange stuff has happened
or some big decisions at least have
happened and uh mostly it's about how
Ariana as black has set up so let's go
back to move one D4 and Knight F6 met by
Bishop F4 the kind of accelerated London
here not messing around with any Knight
F3 just quickly planting the bishop on
that square and after E3 uh tari didn't
play the kind of traditional measures
where you can play moves like C5 you
play E6 you can even sometimes bring
this bishop out instead he encato so
kind of a hybrid system you normally
don't want to go for this or at least
it's less popular these days to set up
like a grinfeld against the London
system and after a few more moves B6
very slow move here finger doing the
other Bishop was met by H4 gukesh wants
to win we can say that that's for sure I
love this move H4 yes B6 we can say that
it's kind of a slow move because you
want to play C5 somehow and and also I'm
not so sure I want to have my Bishop on
B7 necessarily but H4 I like this idea a
lot and maybe White's idea is to play H5
Knight H5 Rook takes H5
uh and just sacrifice in exchange it can
easily happen
we happen and from my experience it's
just extremely scary this type of
position as black white often will just
bring the bishop out move the Knight out
the way uh recapture with this queen and
and suddenly you see the B7 Bishop is
very much away from the action on the
king's side so it would be just standing
much better on CA so this is why H4 is
very tricky because uh you see the Atari
already started to think quite heavily
he spent 24 minutes up to this point and
we are only at the move nine so he is
already hesitating whether can I go
Bishop B7 continuing the plan I started
by playing B6 and of course when you
start hesitating and being insecure
about your position and you know that
actually you play against gokash who's a
very strong player
he's quite younger than his but he knows
it that it's very challenging and of
course it's he's playing with the black
pieces his tournament is not going so
well
so there are a lot of challenges for
tari in this game I think yeah I I just
kind of wanted to add to that point and
uh say according to my database is only
been played once before
but like how would you in a concrete way
handle the very trendy idea of going H4
because now everyone and their mother
are doing these lines
yeah first thing is not to panic but
that's hard that's a difficult first
step and especially as Judith says
aryan's having a really really tough
time here in Stavanger this year so when
you're having a tough tournament you
automatically kind of get scared when
your opponent's playing moves and kind
of going for you signaling their
intentions with uh so directly with a
move like H4 after that you kind of
compose yourself and
yeah there's two approaches you either
kind of Fight Fire with Fire try to lash
out here it's hard to do so because the
center is so fixed that's why kind of
London systems uh London system players
love this setup because it's so hard for
black to kind of counter in the center
against Wing attacks and then I think uh
the other option just kind of going
solid you can do that maybe bring your
Bishop out to G4 trade off some pieces
but then you've kind of wasted a move
with B6
yes at the same time we can say that you
can play B6 and you try to develop with
your plan and then your opponent plays
H4 you're not going to chicken out you
say Okay H4 so now I played B6 but now I
can switch
uh to the other plan as you say Bishop
G4 I think it makes a lot of sense
but it will be some interesting yeah
because after Bishop G4 maybe the White
Queen will be going to B3 or C2 and then
Knight E5 comes so what I see that
gokash wants to play a very sharp game
even though it's a London system it's
supposed to be quite solid for some time
at least it's already with H4 it shows
that the gokash has some sharp and
tactical uh ideas
yeah and I should mention as well Magnus
Carlson is on record saying he used to
play the London system just kind of on
autopilot just Bishop out push the pawns
to E3 C3 just play a game but nowadays
he says the London system has been
ruined because everyone studied all the
move order details they know too much so
many forcing lines and also for black
players the London systems become so
much harder to meet when I was young
it's just regarded as an opening by you
know lazy players these days it's uh all
about hard work and H4 H5 is going to be
part of his prep there's very aggressive
ways to play the London system it's not
just autopilot anymore so for Ariane who
maybe has been caught unawares here
already bad news he's burnt half an hour
on the clock and
um yeah I think he's been tricked in the
move order in the opening already
wow it's a start with some mixed
fortunes there we can see some players
like heading for a draw we can also see
some tense setups and usual setups and
of course some fiery setups so I think
it's the perfect time to take our first
break so don't miss the action and stay
tuned
[Music]
thank you
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
then compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
wow that's amazing puzzles
different possible positions after two
moves nine million different possible
positions after three moves
318 billion different possible positions
after four moves I'm gonna play the
London seriously I'm sorry
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and hello and welcome back
everybody and before we dive into the
action time to mention the 2023 speed
chess season begins with the junior
speed Chess Championship on June the
13th this four day event showcases the
best young talent in speed chess with
over 45
000 on the line but the real prize goes
to the top finisher alone who moves on
to the main speed Chess Championship
later this summer catch all the actions
starting June the 13th right here at
twitch.tv forward slash chess use xclam
jscc in chat for all the details and
who's playing in the jcscc and Ohs well
good cash and talking about kukesh
he's now playing classical chess and
these fast-paced time controls how on
Earth do you prepare for them oh and in
the meantime just before we answer that
question there has been a result both
Shakura mamajov and Magnus
they are just about to kind of seal that
deal now seal the draw with a repetition
of moves we're about to see a handshake
it's all been simplified it's simply a
symmetrical Queen end game why does
giving checks Black's King is moving
you're going back and forth and
any second now
that is three times they have repeated
the position makes the move wait for
Magnus
to react and it is a draw
and that means the two will be playing
an Armageddon game in approximately 20
minutes a peaceful outcome in classical
chess but it will be a full-blooded
fight when it comes to the Armageddon
game
and there we see Sherry the Arbiter
picking up the score sheets
not unexpected Judith
oh yeah I mean just what less than half
an hour ago we were discussing that well
the outcome we are expecting to have a
draw and the max one hour well it was
faster than that but I'm still hoping
for a great fight in the Armageddon
because there there is nothing to be
lost for mamajarov he has to go all in
and fight for victory yes absolutely and
I guarantee that I they the players have
to the time control demands it white
will be in a must-win situation and
okay
so we have lots of games still
continuing
shall we pop in to our tournament leader
Fabiano Fabiano's game
he faces off against Wesley so
is this a day of exchanges as we see
also a lot of pieces leaving the board
on that encounter I don't know what raid
they are exchanging in their pieces but
it seems like in Fabiano's game also it
goes to direction that it's simplified
and the white is little bit has a more
space advantage or more development and
white ones to go after Bishop G5 Rook E1
control the E file but still I feel that
there is very very small
um
if there is anything for writing this
position I would go Queen f8 for example
to make space for for my rook and bring
it to E8 which of course rookie one will
be played after that but somehow I have
the feeling that black is uh is having
not a very difficult position for the
moment
yeah let's uh jump in briefly with an
action replay to show how they got here
we last left this game about seven eight
moves ago and it has completely changed
it has completely blown up we left it
here after a trade of Pawns in the
center black is just recaptured on D5
and after some very standard developing
moves Bishop to D3 black protruding
Bishop D6 we saw eventually it was
Fabiano who decided to open the center
before it's too late before the Black
Knight jumps into the middle and blocks
the white structure here he thought okay
E4 uh leading to all of these trades
takes takes takes takes takes takes
takes takes everything and uh 97 the
last move before Bishop G5 happened is
that the first time in your career
commenting career where you've managed
to get
intakes and a juicer is gone
hits the queen yeah I'm not used to it
I'm not as good as Hikaru at that phrase
but uh Judah as well uh you mentioned
Queen f8 for a standard move met by
rookie one but Queenie eight maybe yeah
I'm just realizing that Queen E8 can be
a smarter way of dealing with the bishop
G5 move and it was while I was saying
take Stakes takes I thought why not take
the Queens off the board as well
and not easy for white to keep the
tension the problem is if you move the
queen away
um where should we put her but white
cannot exchange the queen so it's
definitely something that white has to
be moving away with the queen to D3 or
maybe D3 is a is a good move D3 and now
let's say for example I kick your Bishop
we could well see a sequence for example
hitting the black queen now the white
Bishop moves and own sorry the black
queen is the white Bishop moves and now
after wait rookie eight isn't possible
Queen D3 is a clever Square Reader I was
about to say rookie eight but you're
hitting this Pawn on A6
well in the right side the plan I think
is Knight E5 somehow centralized the
Knight
if the black queen would be on D5 life
is kind of better isn't that the kind of
standard tricks so for instance if you
were to go rookie eight
and then the Rooks were to get swapped
off
I was thinking about
can you guess it can you guess the F5
you get Queen taste for an F5 and the
whole idea is that you you got to trap
the bishop wow nice idea
very nice idea G5 I can stop that oh the
bar doesn't disprove yeah it says black
has that actually a small Advantage
despite being down a pawn Ivanka so I
think you're right maybe this is
annoying uh very nice idea yeah I don't
see how to save this bishop for white
suddenly so this is the kind of thing
that uh maybe Wesley will rely on in the
current position we are expecting him
after a bit of thought to play Queen E8
but it's not necessary yet uh maybe
he'll just choose another Square for his
Queen I like this one just because later
on for example if you do move the queen
out the way again the BlackRock has
easier access to the open file looking
actually after Queen D3 also F6 can be
interesting and to place the queen to F7
yeah with light Squad Bishops on the
board this would be Unthinkable but here
looks very logical uh just creating a
square
well you don't want to make weaknesses
like on E6 but uh
it can be interesting
but I can always play a move like B5 as
well bring the Knight around to B5 to D5
uh we'll see a similar theme in another
game that we'll soon jump to but yeah
looking Rock Solid for black here Wesley
solved all his opening issues feels like
Fabiano just wants to be solid in this
game
well very much so this is what he shows
that he wants to be under control and
maybe he's not going to be push it too
hard
yeah stuff against Wesley the most solid
man in World Chess uh to eke out an
advantage in the opening and yeah we
can't blame Fabian as well for having
half an eye on the tournament standings
so still early days maybe we'll be
shocked here as long as Queen remain on
the board the draw is far far away
what do we think should we check in on
some of the other action let's check in
on Hikaru Nakamura who's in second place
he's training Fabiano by two points
and he is playing Nordica
sorry uh Abdus turov who is uh not doing
so well in terms of tournament standings
yeah and noddyback has not had a great
few days but Hikaru needs to hope that
continues and he's been trying to
bamboozle uh Abdus here with some
strange Maneuvers Judith uh in the break
we were discussing how many times this
Black Knight has moved uh Hikaru has had
12 moves with black
it has moved six times out of 12 moves
half of this moves have been with this
Knight and two of those other 12 was
with the other Knight which has now
disappeared
what do you make of this modern chess
yeah sometimes I'm not sure I understand
uh some decisions but the the Knight on
D5 stands very nicely and I guess the
idea is that it's provoking white to
play C4 which after is going to make
another night move goes to B4 or of
course E7 is also a nice good spot and
after that to play D5 but maybe on B4 it
can also makes sense so it seems like
black things that those moves pawn moves
which was made in the last few moves
b3a4 it is not on White's favor but
actually it can be weaknesses and the
move Rook from E2 to E1 that was
something interesting for me like uh
what white has in mind why was it so
important to move away The Rook right
now is he want to go Queen H5 for
example and then bring the bishop out to
D3
yeah very aggressive Queen H5 Bishop D3
looks logical I'm wondering how black
sets up as well
and after all after all the Rook stands
more natural on E1 yeah
can I also say that this position as
Quirky as it is has been played before
it was a high level encounter between
Vichy Anand and the Sergey kariakin wow
and that game ended in a draw and I
think perhaps to meet Judith's idea of
playing Queen H5 black played C6
okay so preemptively just defending this
Black Knight maybe preparing a nice home
for it after C6 the Black Knight can
always drop back to C7 if it really
needs to
yeah logical solid move here but maybe
Nakamura think of something more
ambitious and I do like that comment
from chat why has all their pieces on
the back rank as well fair point
we shouldn't uh we shouldn't praise it
though remember who is the Fisher random
world champion it's Hikaru Nakamura you
cannot play like this Fisher random
chess against Hikaru
yeah that's a good spot actually
at the same time sometimes your Bishops
can be more powerful on its initial
squares like C1 and F1 than when they
are out for example in this position
white cannot have a better place for the
bishop I believe the Black Knight is
controlling the important F4 Square
Bishop on B2 I'm not sure I would be
very happy to put it there my Bishop so
the C1 Bishop I'm quite okay and F1
Bishop will come out to D3 one day sorry
my arrow there going crazy but yeah
Bishop D3 quite likely to happen maybe
bishop C4 if you really want to evict
this Black Knight
uh yeah actually I'm I kind of I'm a
sucker for retreating Bishop moose I
just love keeping them safe for later in
the game and making sure that they
survive till the end game and
yeah very tense position uh I agree with
the featured chat here can't wait to see
Hikaru in the confessional I have a
feeling we'll find out a bit more maybe
he's aware of that uh kind of
predecessor that game by Anand
and he's just weighing up his options
I I I'm also looking forward to hikaru's
confession and I thought it was very
interesting that oh it's the seventh
move with the knight seven out of 13
moves with the same piece Hikaru sorry
go on your Banker uh no but we just also
saw Hikaru just uh get up officer with a
smile leave and uh for abdicator of he's
uh in tank that for sure is going to be
a new move that's a lot of Night Moves
it's like the night's gone on The Grand
Tour of the chessboard you know where is
it going to find a home and it's not the
Final Destination this is for sure it's
either going to go to G6 or F5 in the
next time try the center it wasn't happy
there Queen side hmm
yeah oh yeah yeah it really reminds me
of a game hikar who played in Gibraltar
one year where he made I think like six
or seven Queen moves in a row uh just in
the Dutch defense he kind of brought his
Queen out to B6 took on B2 just moved
his Queen all the other pieces sat at
home uh didn't develop them but who
needs other pieces when you have one
active uh piece so he got away with it
as well I mean and this is the problem
with high level chairs
they break the rules
and every everything we've ever been
told and they get away with it and they
they make it actually seem Supernatural
that is actually the way you should be
playing when uh eight times out of ten
shouldn't be doing this you've got to
know the rules to break the rules that's
true
no I would
I would agree I just want to defend that
pawn on D4 so I can free up my queen
from D1 and go to E2 for example
controlling the line or playing Knight
D2 with the plan of Knight F3 or Play
Bishop D3 so I need the D4 poem to be
protective
I like the other idea Jude at C3 in
order to lift The Rook okay two rookie
two later on I like that but you're
blocking in your beautiful Bishop on F1
I'll play Judas moves first C3 Bishop D3
the pieces will no longer sit at home
they'll eventually come out and if after
C4 black plays D5 even the bishop on C1
plays an important role maybe later on
A3
yeah if black isn't careful there could
be some Targets on this diagonal but
this is incredible that black can make
seven moves on uh out of 13 and he's
he's not going to be punished
it's not as if White's made much use of
the first 13 turns all pieces are still
on the back rank
oh crazy stuff yeah okay well
I I do like this game and C3 the move
that you recommended you did on the
board reinforcing the protection of D4
but the action is still to happen in
this game so should we check out the
bird's eye view and have a look at how
the other games are getting along
and
the ones I'm super curious about are
the ones where
how are they getting on because that was
a somewhat different E4 E5 opening and
then of course we had good Cash's
um well aggressive try there on the king
side so between those two
what game should we go for
looks like kukash's game is heating up
against Ariane just one move being
played in both of those games since we
were last there
um yeah let's jump in with rukesh to see
how the youngster the Indian Prodigy is
getting on against uh ariantari
ambition is the name of the game in this
one with White's H Pawn about to step
forward to H5 Judah I think you've
predicted it this might end up in a
sacrifice whether it works or not it's
another question but it looks like uh go
cash has pretty much forecast his ideas
to tari who's been burning a lot of time
on the clock exactly this is what I
wanted to highlight as well that tari
seems to be not feeling comfortable or
he does not uh feel which direction he
should be moving on in this position and
generally speaking this is this is a bad
sign because when you play an opening
you should be aware of how you're going
to set up your pieces how you're going
to be developing your pieces for example
with a bishop you go to B7 or F5 with
your knight is it idle to go to D7 or C6
so
it's important to understand the
position and what kind of ideas there
are but of course one thing is very
clear that the Atari has to be aware and
check it in every single move what
happens if in the next move H5 and
there's a sacrifice going to happen
and he reacts he chooses finally after a
long long think there he plays Knight B
to D7 he's trying to trade off White's
most centralized piece logical move but
what could be the consequences and does
go cash step forward immediately try to
initiate an attack does he
bring his Bishop out first this bishop
has a couple of very kind of tempting
squares Bishop to D3 Bishop to B5 very
active squares there you can make an
argument for using the queen already
she's uh now capable of jumping out to a
square that's been vacated by one of the
white Knights
makes sense I think to give an extra
boost and stabilization of the E5 Knight
already which we exist there
it makes a lot of sense doesn't it
reinforce the pieces and the Knight on
D2 has no purpose
um but you can also live with at night
on E5 as is and then introduce the light
squared Bishop into the game
I haven't yet decided where to put the
piece though so Bishop D3 Maybe
yeah all tempting options all of these
but I think also it makes sense to take
a look H5
just to play with an idea what really
black is going to be playing is he going
to really capture it with the Knight or
does he dare to capture it with the
Knight or he would be taking on E5 first
and only after that to think about it or
should he leave it there completely and
not react on it yeah let's jump in and
show what happens if gokesh turns into a
caveman and decides to go straight for
that black king H5 as you say Judah on
the board okay I'm going I'm not brave
enough to take yet but I'll take this
Knight first maybe and next move I'm
pretty much gonna pre-move Knight takes
H5 and hope that you don't check mate me
well okay let's go D takes E5 oh you're
gonna check maybe D take C5 oh and oh
wow okay meanwhile a game has started
the Armageddon between Magnus Carlsen
and Shakira mamajarov Mama jar of with
the white pieces and a quick start to
this one it's the English opening a
couple of pieces off the board already
at this early stage yes and uh I'm just
going to briefly mention that you guys
wanted a Hikaru confessional and we have
a Hikaru confessional and we'll play
that during the break
and there we see Shaq stepping up with
his Queen side Pawns
ah
A4 on the board from Shaq stepping
forward with the queen side pawns and
okay Magnus just basically playing a
sicilian but with reverse colors uh
looks healthy to me black set up here
Judith who do kind of hold us the
favorite at this early stage well I like
Black's position as it is uh pretty
healthy I'm not sure this A4 is
it's there but of course in this
position white Bishop from C1 it has a
challenging test that where is it gonna
go or it will stay there forever
interesting A5 move which was done by
mamajarov pushing the pawn if black is
not going to be stopping A6 then I
believe mamajaro is planning to push all
the way and also probably Queen A4 is
something that he might be continuing or
queen B3 but I'm kind of surprised to
have this spawn push on the A5
especially so early in the game you know
you're kind of taught that you have to
develop your pieces
and Shaq is saying you know what I'm
just going to attack on the queen side
and just whoa I was not expecting that
is determined that magnus's king lives
on the king side
a shack attack is real but he's
forgetting to develop his pieces White's
pieces do not look ready for this
opening of the position Judah well nine
years ago when I stopped in competitive
chess this was not the way it was
considered the way to success
[Laughter]
without developing you have one
developed piece on G2 it's just very
strange yeah but now he's going for your
planetly student putting some pressure
on this Black Knight but the problem is
I mean yes that there's pressure on the
Black Knights but take a look at why
it's night on G1 how on Earth is that
getting out
or probably the next move to play Knight
F3 yeah but then Bishop H3 is also
something to think of I can also imagine
that in the next move let's say black
plays D5 or F5 making it a more active
play with black
yeah I understand what Shaq is trying to
do he's trying to open the position
because he has Bishops but he's just not
ready to do that and actually it's the
side who's facing the bishop pair who
should be trying to speed up the play
here so yeah Magnus it looks like he's
got all of his pieces in the game nice
centralization everything holding
together
time Advantage is disappearing now it's
less than a minute and a half difference
between the two I think in terms of
start to this game not super promising
for Mama jarov Magnus could he goes
seven out of seven in the armageddon's
I spoke to him on the rest day and I can
reveal he said he was shocked that he's
holding his nerve in the Armageddon he
says he doesn't know how it's happening
uh of course he said he'd give
everything for one classical win but the
Armageddon is where he's doing the
business and okay Pawn takes pawn and
okay question here take that pawn with
the Knight or simply recapture it with a
Pawn on E5
that pawn on A6 I kind of we laughed at
it a little bit but it's a great in-game
porn so definitely oh I spoke too soon
it is excuse me game game as the Queens
leave the board
yeah if it was anyone else in the world
I think Magnus would have taken with the
pawn but against Mama jarov getting the
Queen's off tends to be uh good wisdom
there so Queens have left White's Pawn
structure
not necessarily the worst well black
probably wants to go Bishop C6 to
eliminate the white square bishop and A6
spawn can be a weakness also in the
later stage yep your prediction came
true and those Bishops will be leaving
the board
from Miss blacklock's Pawn breaks now or
Lux effective Pawn breaks so it feels
like white is at least got some level of
stability and those Bishops traded as
predicted but is white A6 Pawn enough to
give Shaq serious winning chances
remember shark playing with the white
pieces is in a must win situation
yeah this white A6 born could be backed
up nicely by White Knight if you could
imagine a teleportation device this
White Knight on H3 somehow landing on V5
attacking these pawns but right now it
doesn't really uh kind of make a great
impression I was just thinking about
that dude that don't be fine but how do
I get there right Knight G1 then I have
to do what Knight E2 somehow but then E3
Pawn is hanging you need nakamura's
Knight to dance around uh you need a
similar Journey could you put it on A3
but then it gets but then it gets
stopped by a Pawn on C6 anyhow
what to put it to A3 it's also
but you just don't reach that spot
Magnus breaking out in the center and uh
in terms of the clock situation remember
Magnus did start with a three minute
deficit over chakra Magnus has just got
there four and a half minutes whereas
Shaq has six and a half minutes
and Magnus withdraw odds will want to
play solidly I think that influenced his
Queen trade decision and now this last
Pawn push I said he didn't have any pawn
breaks I just assumed he wouldn't want
to undouble White's pawns whites C pawns
here uh here kind of traditionally not
favoring white but Magnus is happy to
trade off just to get his Knights active
and there we see
both the Black Knights now in the middle
of the bud beautiful settings for black
look at two Rooks on the open file two
nights in the center just idly placed
yeah just beautiful centralization but
he has to move one of them the Knight on
D5 was attacked hits the white Rook now
but that night on B4 is going to get
anchored there with the C7 Pawn and wow
White's position is beginning to look
like
it's not good and there you go C5 I mean
there's no coordinate coordination
whatsoever with white pieces well
finally there is a little idea that the
right place let's say Bishop D2 and
somehow when the Knight moves away from
B4 Knight F4 to D5 can jump in
yeah he starts with the other move order
say my dear Judith uh first some
pressure though especially the white E2
Pawn the base of this chain uh it's a
bit vulnerable you have to over protect
this Pawn somehow before the White
Knight gets kicked away from its
protection you need to keep this chain
intact otherwise your whole position
falls apart sure
H4 looks good just to prevent Pawn to G5
and okay he you chooses instead to use
his King to defend the E2 born and a
question mark making White's position
worse C5 Knight D4
oh or immediately jumping in first big
big threat on the board black wants to
play that move you mentioned Judith G5
hitting kicking away the White Knight
then the E-2 Pawn will fall
so how to deal with that I think he has
to push the pawn uh the H Pawn to cover
that threat
what else you don't want to touch
anything around your king you don't want
to touch your Pawns
you'll only weaken them instead he
brings his Bishop out to block the black
Rook on the E file it feels shaky well
it's holding together for now for white
well Knight bc2 is would be provoking
and the white would have to take on D4
for sure but now maybe just Knight moves
away to F5 for example so after that
already Bishop goes back to D2
black knight from the center ever moves
then white will step back and try to
eliminate this piece
is it too rough if white goes black goes
rookie 3 and G5
wow sacrificing here dude no fear at all
Rook taste Bishop on the board wow
that would not have even been on my
radar sacrificing in an end game but the
whole idea is tactical he's gonna break
apart White's Pawn chain once he's
kicked the Knight away and Magnus looks
up at the screen the evaluation bar
doesn't react meaning this sacrifice is
well Justified and Magnus looking
pretty happy there on the camera you've
got to say looking away as if he's just
kind of proud of his move proud of his
idea
looks nice I'm gonna admit yes it
certainly looks nice and it's bearing in
mind that uh Shaq is in a must win
situation and his white Rooks are just
not coordinating well Knight has to move
the E2 Pawn will drop and then Shaq just
has to get on with the job of relocating
The Rook on A4 which is doing nothing
yeah where to put that note that's the
first question does he centralize it
potentially at the cost of a pawn I
think Knight D5 is the only move for
white
he hesitated there Mama jarov that
Knight is it going to get ignored is it
going to get captured
Magnus gives a check
the white king where to go now
go back I think all the way to G1
running away it has to as you say flee
back to the corner but now can't uh
Magnus to Simply trade Knights and step
back and grab those Pawns
yeah we're expecting Magnus to trade off
white tonight that's the best piece
right now as you say Ivanka take this
one and then somehow maybe go back for
this Pawn that's the radio yeah it's
also tempted to actually grab the pawn
on D3 immediately with a knight exactly
Knight D3 and then Knight D5 and G4
to F3
if you can come to F3 with any of the
knights this black king is simply uh the
white king sorry is going to be caught
in a box animated but of course there
are several ideas it's only that for
black it's uh tricky what to choose out
of the several options what would you
choose to Judith here Magnus only needs
a draw he can choose a safer option if
he needs which one's very much tempted
to go Knight D3 I'm not sure that's the
best but um I somehow would go Knight D3
and Knight E5 or Knight E1 at some point
then G4
you love that 91 move it keeps happening
this tournament
full board Vision there Knight E1 coming
in watch out for that to happen Judith
predicted it correctly every time I
think Knight takes D3 on the board
Magnus makes a bit of a face he knew
that was a difficult decision and he's
under two minutes
so he needs to speed up what's manager
going to do to complicate the issue this
white Rook on a4s he said to your Banker
just worst place worst piece was placed
peace on the board
where to go what to do not easy it's
certainly not easy and also you have to
bear in mind that black has ideas of
anchoring a knight on F3 so and that
would be curtains for the white king
I was looking at moves like 95 trying to
get the Knight immediately in with check
it's very powerful as well yeah and okay
I mean White's only move is actually to
try and trade off works
and that's going to be a very difficult
job as well well now White's only plan
can be that after Knight E5 he goes Rook
F2
black snakes are so beautiful right now
Magnus will be reluctant to move them
but he really has to speed up he's got
about one minute 10 seconds now and it's
still 12 13 moves before he gets any
increment at all so he has to make
minimum 12 or 13 moves
in one minute and he's looking away from
the board
what's this he needs to hurry up
it's going to be physically difficult
he's playing G5 G4 immediately well this
allows Knight F6 check grabbing a pawn
the Knight can check and take the
support next move
but this would lead maybe to a draw
because after check King goes out Knight
to G4 I think Black Goes H5
yeah White's night is kicked all the way
back
and if neither two then Knight F3 and
Knight even some kind of perpetuation
but the problem is Knight F3 is such a
serious threat if the Black Knight
arrives there then you have um check
mating ideas with the Rook taking H2
massive threat on the board Mama jar of
under three minutes now has to deal with
this one I think I would just give this
check now and just hope to survive if
you don't have any options as mamajara
if you should just try and play quickly
not give Magnus time to think
calculation needs to be done of course
but he has plenty of times for a moment
two and a half minutes
and if he calculates uh ahead then he
can play his moves not only one but
several moves quickly yeah but Magnus
will do the same
to pause now or to pause later that's
the question I agree with the featured
chat just flag him just move not too
many options here from amajarov I'm
looking for others maybe he can hit the
there is D1 yeah hit one of the Black
Knights with his Rook
that must be the only real alternative
maybe you can yeah it's just so
difficult he just needs to decide as the
featured chat says white has definitely
got ideas of sacrificing on the B6
Square later for White's a point to run
through but first you have to deal with
your king so he actually steps back with
his Knight trying to trade off makes a
lot of sense as well but right now maybe
Knight F3 is also possible I know
because it takes a knight D3
and uh there we see a trade of knights
and again Magnus now has to play very
quickly at advances IS F Pawn and Magnus
has a dream position all his pieces are
well placed and why its works are just
not coordinated
yeah Rooks thrive on open files and if
you notice Magnus has blocked every
single open file but look at this a
sacrifice in the air watch out for Rook
takes Pawn followed by the white Pawn
promoting we mentioned something similar
earlier this white a pawn is White's
only hope
oh
and okay is it on the cards now that's
the question Rook takes Pawn
Magnus he's allowed it to happen if root
takes porn maybe is he going to ignore
that there's some counter attacks
against the white king and okay now the
Black Knight has stepped back he defends
everything no sacrifices available and
whites Rooks looking for those open
files can he plug that open file with
his Knight with the Black Knight
he's going to have to um Magnus now
under 20 seconds oh I see a cross next
to magnus's move that means a missed
opportunity maybe there's something
stronger well maybe now rookie 2 can be
unpleasant or at least fighting
fighting for something from White's
point of view on the board we're going
to see the Rooks leave the board Knight
comes in
Black's night has lost a lot of power
with that trade of Rooks now it's going
to be incredibly tough to stop White's
Rook from infiltrating later but he's
using his King Magnus aggressively it's
going to be a race simply and who's
ahead here
Black's pawns running
um black spawn is really running
but the a pawn is so close
whites Rook has to get greedy here
simply has to capture the pawn and hope
for the best
Shack's being accurate so far as
mentioned in the future chat but is it
enough to win black spawns are so fast
yeah but after C2 yeah this was a smart
move I believe
very smart covering the promotion
squares and now black will simply
threaten to push his pawn it might cost
white his Rook unless now he abandons
the defense of his a pawn seven seconds
for black
yeah like this he's got a one second
increment now but that's no luxury it's
uh not enough one second over the board
okay
White's gonna move his Rook very tricky
position what's he played rookie two but
that gives up the A6 Pawn
gives up the A6 pawn and look his pawns
are running now Shaq looks away even at
the cost of the Black Knight Magnus is
gonna win the game the Pawn's too strong
and he won the game with five seconds on
his clock and uh once again Magnus wins
the Armageddon match the Armageddon King
he is the Armageddon King he can take
solace in that but he's still yet to win
a classical game and then we see Magnus
leave the board with a smile and
and uh
and uh there we can see David there was
a potential Miss from Magnus yeah there
was a potential Miss actually we'll show
how that game ended and uh yeah great
technique for Magnus in the end in this
position we saw the Red Cross appear a
missed opportunity from Magnus actually
black would have been doing very well
after simply capturing this Pawn with
his Rook but as we saw he Advanced his
King instead and after white swapped off
the Rooks maybe here mama jarov had
better had other options uh including
going forward with his King right now
trying to break forward with the white
king because look what happened after
just one passive move from mamajarov
going passive with his Rook it was the
black king that came forward and if we
fast forward to the end of the game
small mistakes here for white including
that last Rook move Rook takes F5 as we
see because now the black pawns simply
ran and it was already too late the key
move here the killer move and the only
move to win the game King to B2 helping
and supporting this black pawn from
running through the whole idea is that
the white Rook when it does move it has
to move suddenly white spawn disappears
and as we saw the rest is over B5 was
good enough and C2 black wins the game
with his ex reports
nice moments from Magnus there and I
think after that hair raising Adventure
between the two players I think is the
perfect time for a break
and let's not forget that during the
break they will be seeing Hikaru in the
confessional and that is just for twitch
subscribers so
Let's uh subscribe to Twitch and listen
to what Hikaru has to say
welcome back everyone so we are now
playing in round number eight here in
Norwich house of course yesterday was
arrested there are no games
um today I'm playing with the black
because it has no Rebecca as I usually
do I will talk about the other games
first that way there will be no fun
edits or
um so first and foremost in the game
between gookesh and tari gukesh has
played the classic London system he's
basically just trying to get tari out of
theory out of preparation just play
chess no computers no prep none of none
of this nonsense that modern chess
generally is so that's the first game
now the game between Magnus and chakra
we have a pretty standard Queen's gamp
decline so far a big question whether
magazine plays C5 whether he'll play
um or whether he'll play the Knight bd7
variations Heroes and Shaq has played
Bush buff 4 and E3
um but it's definitely going to be
dynamic I think in that game
um the game between Wesley and Fabiano
oh yeah it's the nimso Indian this
classic Bishop D2 E3 which I've actually
played a lot of in recent times
um so again very early hard to know
what's going to happen in that game I
assume less will be well prepared but
flabiano definitely wants to put some
pressure on him so that's the third game
and then what is the other game that I'm
forgetting there's one in the game ah
yes there's Ali rez's game against Anish
giri and Ali Raza played e45 93 96 and
G3 a very similar situation I think
where Ali Raza sick and tired of playing
Theory and on each obviously one of the
best repair best prepared players out
there so he's just trying to avoid
Theory and play Shots once again and
then of course we come to my game
against
um I guess Notre back and we have the
same opening that we had in my first
round game against Wesley so up to this
move Knight C4 now I'm not actually sure
if Knight C4 has been played before I
have looked at this line obviously in
the past even even prior to the game
against Wesley but I figured out of the
possible moves which are playable it's
probably the it's probably the most
obscure the most unnatural looking move
so that's why I chose to play it out of
the four possibilities in this position
um so I'm pretty happy with what I've
done now the fact that no Rebecca is
thinking is is is potentially very good
for me but also potentially not very
good for me because one of the downsides
to this game is that
um motorbeck lost his previous two games
so he lost to uh I think he lost a five
I think he lost to Fabiano and then he
lost to Wesley some very very bad games
I mean the game against Wesley was sort
of inexplicable I guess you could say
for a player of motorbike's caliber and
so having lost two in a row I was a
little bit worried that he might try to
be more solid in this game and
unfortunately it turns out like that
intuition is right so I have a feeling
either of this either notary is going to
spend a lot of time looking for
something creative to keep the game
going or very likely this game is going
to Peter out into a draw and I'm not
necessarily thrilled by that on the one
hand but on the other hand sword you
never know with Notre Beck he's a player
who can be very aggressive he can also
be very solid I think in terms of the
overall Tournament standings and looking
for something exciting it's it's for me
objectively very bad that he lost to in
a row because certainly his confidence
is down he's not feeling as good about
himself and so it's a lot less likely
that he wants to take the risks and when
you also consider the fact that tomorrow
he has to play with the black piece
against Magnus I mean it could very
easily turn into a situation where he
loses four games in a row to finish the
tournament obviously nobody wants that
and so
um I think as far as my game goes
probably I'm expecting it's probably
going to place me very conservative like
C3 and 92 or something to trade the
pieces B3 Knight B6 he can play C4 or a
for both these
I guess you could say but are playable
either way again as far as I recall the
position should be completely fine so it
is what it is I'm not super happy but
you know life goes on and that's that's
that so I'll probably be back later and
if I'm not back later that means I'm
playing an argument again inside the
next 30 minutes so cheers
thank you
[Music]
hello
hello and welcome back and there once
again we had Hikaru in the confessional
Booth giving us his in-depth thoughts
what do you guys think about this
well it seems like like he was preparing
for this few minutes to really explain
what's going on and it's interesting
that he also felt that not their back is
going to go solid against him yeah
and someone who is not in the
confessional Booth is Magnus Carlson who
is joining us here in the studio so
Magnus you just defeated shakuria
mamajov in an Armageddon game how are
you feeling
I feel okay you know a nice short day of
work
but if it was an intense game at for the
Armageddon that was yeah I was I felt
like I was in control for for most of
the game and then yeah suddenly I wasn't
and uh we had a bit of a uh crazy
scramble there but
um you know it was fun it was a fun game
like not the most high pressure moment
considering our standing in the
tournament but yeah still nice to come
out on top obviously and were there any
moments that you particularly enjoyed uh
and well enjoys maybe a bit too much but
um yeah so if you go a couple of moves
before this uh
okay
well maybe around here
yeah so I chopped off the I chopped off
The Rook uh sorry the bishop and E3
um which I thought made a lot of sense
um
I mean I don't have to do it I can also
make some neutral move and I'm not sure
how he's improving that much but I
thought it was you know principled
um and yeah 95
so I thought for quite a bit like right
around here but I thought I had
everything figured out but it turns out
I I didn't so rookie eight and
um yeah so king of F2 attacks uh maybe
here it would have been more prudent
just to take on on D5 and then rookie
five uh that's that was my original
uh original idea
um but I don't know why I didn't go for
it because I also saw the trick that um
if he then goes rugby one
um
yeah if you go through P1 I have 92 and
Knight C3 with uh with a fork
um
so I think this would have been would
have been very safe but then I sort of
decided beforehand that I was just gonna
treat this game as a normal game I was
going to try and try and win
um so I thought let's not you know beg
for a draw and go through the principled
way uh but I'd simply miscalculate it
here uh first of all I think Rook A3
Rook A3 is a good move instead of um
Rook A1
[Music]
um
and um here I was considering just to
play uh Knight
uh 95 and allow the trade of Rooks
because I get another another pawn and I
don't think I'm don't think I'm worse
um or yeah I I think black is probably
one one who has slight chances of it
although it should be a drop so
anyway uh rookie won he played
uh and here I thought I'd figured
everything out when I played G4 and
there's this nice idea if Knight F6 goes
uh to take on a G4 then I go then I go
F5
um
no and not H5 because I'm not F6 yeah
but F5 and now I've Rook D1 I have well
first of all I have um gf3 uh sorry fg4
and then Knights
F3 with um immediate draw but I also
have Knight B2 which should and which
should win
um
yeah so
and also if Knight F2 instead of Rook D1
uh then negative three
and now the key is King H1
and here I can simply go like Rook C2 I
think
because if I take the Knight there is uh
and after disking see it's looking G2
oh I didn't see that okay it was a good
thing this didn't happen then
but it's almost six one right white can
barely move yeah this is the thing so
okay so I'm not Rook C2 but I I can just
make any move yeah
that's true
but also the point of Rook C2 is that
white didn't have a thread but obviously
since
um
I I kind of need the the rook and E2 to
192 after King G2 or even Knight T1 with
a perpetual
okay yeah but just uh basically nmp is
20 square like some improving move like
H5 or
something black should be doing
extremely well
uh okay uh but what I'd missed I thought
also Knight F4 I'd I'd play Knight F3
and Rook F3 gf3 and 92 fe2 but he takes
my knight instead which I realized
uh way too late
and then I was in a situation where I
had a minute left and and a position
that was suddenly really unclear and
kind of hard to con to control and then
I think
a lot of things probably happened yeah I
wasn't worried uh he could have
they can't be six
yeah you could have attacked on B6 but
then we trade everything I go attack the
opponent C4 with my knight and I I don't
think I should lose
um
just to show this variation yeah take
take
yeah Knight of three and 95 should be
completely fine
um or actually I'm winning the pawn
immediately because we're going to
Knight D3 to B2
um
yeah okay so
a lot of things happened in the game uh
I think
as they say mistakes were were made uh I
I assume King E6 apparently was poor
uh yeah he should have just jumped in
with the Rook that was I think his best
chance
and it's not so easy for me to to trade
off all the all the Pawns
um yeah I suspect this is probably
close to to Lust For Me
um but the way he played was was really
it was really exciting because we got a
we got ourselves the race
um King D4
hey I'm just curious as to yeah okay so
now he's actually much worse yeah
King C4 so probably from here on on we
played well yeah or I played played even
though I had seconds you know the moves
were really really simple
just go push
uh yeah King B3 Rook F7 C4
and um
so this was the one important moment
fortunately I had like
a couple seconds to figure out king B2
because c c two King D2 probably just
probably loses for me I would guess
yes yes
we assume when we see the bar and then
okay so this is interesting that it's
just winning for me because he could
have gone Rook B7
uh and then just go queenie's Pawn
um
oh it is a draw
no I I assumed it was I saw that Queen
C4 was an easy Perpetual
um because his King is never going up
because of Knight D5 but I I didn't
realize it was was just mate but uh
probably it is maybe I can give it give
checks to E3 with the queen and then go
Knight D3 or something oh
something like this you come in
the bar is going crazy something like
this you mean yeah something like this
queen D2 or queen of yeah okay so King
F1
but we can give checks from let's say D1
F3 and then E3
[Music]
to protect the pawn on Basics there's
some tracks over here I don't know if
that helps
yeah so T3 yeah Knight D3
uh okay let's just see if there's
anything crazy going on in the other
games because I I don't want to take all
of people's time looking through this
Army getting game but it's a fascinating
stuff it was interesting to me that's a
realist yeah now the computer says draw
but
um anyway I mean a draw
it wouldn't have changed the results
because um obviously a draw was was
smooth enough from here
and uh just out of curiosity
you want all your Armageddon games so
tomorrow are you gonna try and make a
clean sweep
[Laughter]
um yeah I don't know
um
so today
I felt I sort of felt like I had had
enough and in a sense I mean the the
game against dalareza was just really
the last the last rock kind of um and um
I I was happy to have a short game I
mean
there I'm not gonna not gonna deny deny
that I mean if he'd wanted to play then
then I was fine with that but I wasn't
gonna Force the action
um tomorrow
I don't know
um I mean
yeah I haven't
thought that much
about it
probably wouldn't be crazy opposed to a
short day but
we'll see okay and uh let's checking out
the bird's eye view we see a lot of some
action happening in some of the games I
mean which one catches your fancy
yeah I think Wesley is solid as usual
uh so I don't expect really
crazy things to happen there although
yeah fobby is a little bit
a little bit better maybe uh it's a
little bit of a grip
um I really like aryan's last move
Knight G4
some
uh yeah that's really really cool idea
also good cash going H4 in the opening
was uh I wouldn't say a surprise because
I think that's what you're supposed to
do uh like no joke in general like
one black place
um like sort of slowly and doesn't put a
lot of pressure on the center you should
usually start attacking
um
but
uh yeah now I
think our ins position definitely has
has potential
um you can go E5
don't think there's an attack for for
white so
looking pretty uh
pretty promising for uh for him apart
from that I thought of the turf was a
little bit better
from the opening
um I'm not so sure if he made the most
of his last few moves
um
now hikar has probably
equalized I would say
um
and yeah the last game between others
and
is
now hard to say G4 is extremely ugly but
may not be so bad
uh it kind of looks like some
positions you get from the
from the merlor Spanish except
the white Bishop would be on on C2 but
also in those lines you sometimes just
go G4 like Fabi did that against me once
he just went randomly G4 and in the
murder position and it was just much
better even though I I eventually turned
it around them and won so and it looks
pretty risky for white disposition isn't
it
yeah I'm not really sure what he's
hoping for uh but he has got some some
grip on the center I'm curious as to
what you guys think about the position
we had let's say maybe five six months
ago if White had gone for D5
okay let's backtrack to around here
maybe
yeah so okay some of your Bishop D7
that's clever so I I was thinking uh
that black was going to go Rook
yet and then white probably had to go D5
I thought
um and how such a position would be Yeah
we actually discussed this dude at you
uh Bishop B3 Bishop E3
or maybe C4 first
there's so there are these lines that
were black
plays like
like
um D4
D4 Knight c6c for E5 and then d597 and
so on so this seems like a dream version
of
that for for black yeah yes because the
bishop on A7
A7 but you'll trade off the bishop
done but probably black has a quick F5 I
was not so sure
um
but yeah now how they played they've I
saw that Anish made a real frown when uh
when alares went for for D4 in the
opening because it's in the Italian it's
not so it's not so typical uh to go D4
when you when you're when you're forced
to make concessions early on but um
yeah this is interesting now A3 yeah A3
B5 looks
thematic for for black
um just grabbing some space
yeah I've noticed version he loves to
play A3 anytime his opponents play A4
he's done it against me uh in the grand
Swiss once he's done it a few other
times
even with this kind of weird structure
uh where Black's kind of got a clamp now
on the queen side
yeah
I would even be tempted to start going
maybe not now but some point black can
start think about H5 as well here
yeah probably quite good for
for
um
for for black boots
uh I think alireza is banking on
um Gary having to make some committal
decisions at some point and
he's hoping that um
in order to to sort of
um in order to prove that you're doing
well here as black you'll have to play
aggressively and
his opponent is
um
not necessarily known for for doing so
so maybe that's what he's
hoping for which color would you take
I'd take black probably uh but I
wouldn't I wouldn't hate playing white
here either as long as you got a
position where every piece is on the
board and there's tension in the center
you know you got something
at least relatively exciting
and Magnus do you have any predictions
uh will Fabiano be able to hold on to
his lead in the tournament do you think
anyone might be able to overtake him
well
um
I guess it all comes down to the to the
last round but
obviously it's a pretty significant
favorite so
to bet against him with the even odds
would be foolish yeah
and we have some questions from our chat
uh one from essential Dimension which
says did you ever consider going for
flag
today or when uh
just in general
today today I I flagged some poor poor
lad with Rook against Rook online Reese
uh yesterday actually
we thought actually you spent part of
your rest day getting 3300 on chess.com
was that are you relaxed yeah actually I
was feeling really bad but um I just
yeah I wasn't playing so well but I just
wanted to to win a couple of chess games
um
also you know free days are are long so
you gotta do something with them yeah
yeah but uh
no flag
um as part of this tournament yeah
uh and obviously if I'm playing the
Armageddon and that's the only chance
I'll go for go for the flag if it's even
remotely realistic okay and I completely
agree with you by the way poker brass
asks when is your next poker event
I don't know
I don't have any yeah I don't have any
plants okay
and Henry poncare asks what are your
thoughts on Messi leaving Europe
um I uh
last year when we played uh when you
play the Champions chess Tour event in
in Miami I actually went to to watch
inter Miami
they played like basically out in in the
fields over in Fort Lauderdale I hear
that they're getting a nice new stadium
but the crowd was was good more of a
Latino influence there
um
with some um with some drums and
everything
um and I got myself a nice pink inter
Miami short so
um that one is I think increased
immensely in value the last day so
hopefully uh you know there will be um
uh will be in events there in the future
for instance if there are live Champions
Chester events not the worst place to
have it
Miami's a cool place
and uh
I know on Monday you'll be playing a
play in
yeah
well that's the price I pay for um
cheating on the Champions chess Tour by
playing the grand chest or over the
board
so it's yeah then it's unforgiving and
you you have to
you have to earn your um your dollars
but um
you know
um
I found myself
thinking that uh the the playing
tournament was really fun to to watch
probably less fun to play
and uh yeah now I'm gonna have to play
so
um yeah it's gonna be um it's gonna be
tough for um for sure yeah well good
luck in that and also good luck in your
next game and thank you very much for
appearing on the show so thank you thank
you thank you
so uh
well a great start to round eight
and uh there we see farrugia and Anish
giri
settling in into the action there
and a niche Gary he must have done more
than ten thousand steps pacing up and
down that carpet I have to ask I know
David is not a Pacer
he's rooted to the chair but what are
your thoughts on pacing is that burning
too much energy oh no no walking during
the game and the and after the game I
think it's really a chess player sport
daughter walk around I remember back in
Linda RS when the playing hover we
played the there was the stage and then
there are a lot of chairs and on this
side there was a long path and you could
always see the player standing up from
the board going there and everybody was
going back and forth back and forth back
and forth
so that that was uh I think many of the
players and I also like to to walk
around looking at their games and just
to to get a little bit refreshed and and
also your attention is going away a
little bit also it can be psychological
that you're acting the where's your
opponent that I know what I'm doing I
have a great position I'm confident yes
and uh it was actually really great to
have the insights of the Magnus Carlson
on the the remaining games he told us
that alireza farouza and each giri the
ones we see on camera
that was a tense game either side could
be happy if they just kept the tension
in the center and
I was surprised that the Magnus said
that he would be okay playing it with
white as well
I was very happy to hear that
because my instinct was you know white
has advanced the G4 Pawn
I know it concedes some squares but you
know not the end of the world when you
push some pawns but I love G4 as well
but still somehow I consider it that I
would rather play it with the black side
and that's the thing about top players
uh often if you talk with them after a
game they often think they're doing well
they think they're doing great they were
winning the whole game turn the board
around they still think they're winning
so they're Eternal optimists and uh okay
Magnus choosing black here preferring
anisha's position Anish as we see has
just put his Knight on A5 may be ready
now to lock down the center to kind of
challenge White's Pawn uh kind of
formation here on D4 E4 and just for a
solid position meanwhile unless white
can generate an attack with G5 later on
then the having this kind of slightly
Airy King might backfire so yeah just
very tense and it's interesting we're
nearly two hours in now and two of the
four remaining games still all of the
pieces all of the pawns on the board no
trades at all it shows the tension
mounting here in round eight I said two
of the remaining games
yeah
so so one game has a switched into end
game mode right
yeah which one am I missing two of the
remaining four games still have all the
pieces one is an end game now no no yeah
what I was just saying just two just two
and then I was just saying but the other
two oh exchange Central is what I wanted
to get her yes exchanges all over the
place the vacuum the Hoover is out
between Fabiano caruana and Wesley so
and yeah looking level in that one too I
I uh yeah I mean just looking at the
bird's eye view I mean just a rook and
Knight
and the big question is
draw incoming
Judith what do you think will we see
another Armageddon in the next hour or
so well in the Fabiano game it seems uh
very much that we are heading to that
the direction to have an extra an other
draw but it's not so easy for black to
play this because
what can press it I believe
I don't know exactly whether it's Knight
E5 in the next move for example and then
possibly Knight D3 re regrouping it to
C5
or uh
G4 is also to press a little bit it can
be the move because for now Knight D5
cannot be played because of the A6 Pawn
is under attack the C6 has to be C7 has
to be protected by The Rook on C8
so black is pretty passive for the
moment so black will have to make some
good moves in order to really to
equalize okay so so it is some there is
some unpleasantness for black yeah
absolutely I think Fabi is just having a
good time he's a little pressing it he
will try out this and that and if vesely
does everything fine then he probably
can equalize yeah and
and a grind Master
Grand Master indeed um like Judah I
would definitely take white I'm not sure
how much of an advantage it is but uh at
least momentum wise I really don't like
uh Wesley's last few moves it feels like
he could have maybe had a kind of safer
easier life here in this game uh yeah as
Judah says The Rook is tied down the
night is tied down so it pretty much
means at some point you'll have to start
bringing the king towards the center and
it all depends on the next three or four
moves if white is able to kind of
initiate something or at least set up a
bind long term then great chances but
yeah I very much think we'll have to
update this one in a few turns to see
whether Fabiano can work his magic
squeeze water out of a stone
I actually really like this type of play
because I feel I feel it's very subtle I
find it it's like the height of
intelligence because you have to play on
small little details and you have to
collect those small advantages and just
maximize everything and so let's go back
to the bird's eye view we'll see what
cleverness isn't used in this game
but uh there were a lot of positions
with no pieces
traded off can we go to
nordeback nodie back and Hikaru
yeah so this game there's been only one
set of nights traded off and one set of
Pawns uh this one of course extremely
important for the standings Hikaru away
from the board could that mean another
confessional uh we'll find out soon but
yeah he's been playing relatively fast
up to this point Magna said the worst is
over he thinks Hikaru is fine here but
it's just a question of whether
nodabex space Advantage here on the
queen side with white having these
really far Advanced pawns whether that
amounts to anything
looks good
good usually very impressive white
structure here just the promise no
passports no weaknesses in the black
camp
yeah there are great uh space advantage
on the queen side with the pawns but at
the moment I'm not sure how white is
going to be really make any profit out
of it and Dr Queen C7 now black wants to
go rookie a to start simplifying and
exchanging the Rooks Knight on G7 stands
not bad at all it can come to E6 or once
the bishop is moved away from F5 coming
to F5 kind of provoking the G3 Bishop to
exchange on D6 and later on at some
point if Knight C5 or something like
that would bother black or even to
prevent it black can play B6 so it's not
so easy to get really Advantage
otherwise
I I had an idea
I'm saying and I think it will meet with
frowns from YouTube but I the idea was
basically that
Black's pieces stand very well I'm
looking at the bishop on F5 so I was
thinking Bishop takes Bishop make black
lose a time with the queen and I can see
David has already predicted what I'm
going to say next I want to go G4 and
the whole idea is not really to get
greedy and attack anything it's just
simply to gain the space and
well the evaluation bar levels out I'm
I'm satisfied
well I believe black would be going back
with the bishop all the way to D7 yeah
and after that he would want to continue
with Knight E6 because there is a very
weak spot suddenly on F4
um
what was the follow-up to this plan
Ivanka looks like you've gained space
made one piece passive I have made one
piece passive and I was kind of hoping
to go Knight C5 so I was I was kind of
using some pattern recognition from like
D4 kind of like benoni type things when
you do have this one line open on the
e-line and there you try to gain as much
space as possible but I just thought
Knight C5 and then and then you know you
just hold
nothing
nothing more than that and you know
there is only one line to control and
then switch attention to that line
yeah for example B6 I guess you keep
pieces on do you just retreat with the
white Knights you bring out the queen
and yeah
yeah it still looks yeah very healthy
very solid for white despite having push
points in front of the king there were
definitely worse times to push pawns G4
has been one of the themes of the
tournament seems to happen in every game
so imagine if that does transpire your
anchor great prediction if it does I
would be very much afraid to play this
j4 the long run sorry I'm not a fan of
this this G4 this time
the rare exception you don't want to
play G4 shooter
yeah so this one's very tense I think we
won't see G4 just purely because
abdusatorov has had a tough kind of few
days and it does feel a bit kind of
scary and counter-intuitive to push once
but definitely nothing wrong with that
one but maybe for example to play
between F3 or take on D6 and after that
Queen F3 and trying to exchange it with
Queen G3 that I would consider are also
Queen D2
so the black squares are somehow
something to play on for white yeah and
he's jumped in with the Knights already
and the big question now is for example
does black trying to pick this Knight
instantly or do we trade Bishops and
then try to evict the Knight with uh
Pawn to B6 I don't want to allow this
Knight to sit in this beautiful Square
in the black half for too long
I wonder what Nakamura will go for here
I think he'll be reluctant to allow this
Knight to live on C5 as well
and uh also taking into account
the kind of State nature of the pawns I
mean both sides there are no porn
majorities do you think Hikaru will be
trying to win this or do you think he
will be satisfied with drawing going to
an Armageddon winning that encounter
because in terms of the standings
he has to keep neck and neck with
Fabiano then it's not ideal
yes but in this position I don't think
he can think of winning the game right
now he has to be working very hard for
equalizing completely because it is
white who is pressing
yeah and actually if we think of uh I've
been doing my maths equations if we
think of the standings for example if
Fabiano draws he will be three points
ahead of Hikaru before hikaru's result
in this game and uh let's say Fabiano
wins the Armageddon for Hikaru whether
he wins in classical whether he wins the
Armageddon the job is still the same he
still needs to beat Hikaru he still
needs to beat Fabiano so tomorrow in
order to win the tournament so actually
how much of a lead is not a relevant
factor it's just the fact that he will
be needing to win on Demand with white
against Fabiano so playing it safe here
kind of seeing how things go it makes a
lot of sense the one thing that he
cannot afford is a loss in the classical
because then he'll be out of the race at
Fabiano will be safe home and dry so I
think Hikaru is being very pragmatic we
heard him in the confessional he said if
the opponent plays solid what can you do
with the black pieces sometimes it's
hard to beat the very elite players on
Demand with the black pieces so
I think he's caught in two minds himself
and we've all been that tournament chess
is the hardest thing to have all those
calculations and still kind of have the
peace of mind to play good moves at the
same time I believe that he's checking
on Far Beans game in the meantime while
when he's walking around
and it's uh it's not simple because he
might have the idea that well Fabi is
pressing so it is a very unconvenient
situation that you know that Fabi is
pressing and at the same time you're
having a little uncomfortable position
with black
and meanwhile this game it's very quiet
should we move on to check out some of
the others let's go to the bird's eye
view first of all
uh Hikaru yeah according to mines winner
of the draw he needs one of those
results and which game where should we
go Judah we haven't been in the gokash's
game for some time and there was some
interesting way of reacting by tari
very interesting play that uh led the
game a little bit on the different
direction
because I did not think that white is
going to be castling in that game I
thought that some way or another white
is going to be pushing H5 and contrary
black played H5 and played Knight G4 so
White's initiative is not as it was
before at the same time Knight on C6
it's very active but the
it's kind of a tricky place for the
night because it gives some
unpleasantness for black and it's like
I'm there I'm trying to attack you just
in case
but still eventually once black is
moving away for example with the Knight
white probably has to play B5 to
stabilize it but still it can be
eliminated and also E5 is something what
the black can play for any time
and the fact that white had to Castle or
I mean he castled I'm not sure I'm so
happy that white has H4 born over there
yeah it all depends on whether this
Knight can live as you say Judith on G4
because uh you've kind of given it a
nice home by pushing your h-bone on the
other hand uh you have to be careful
that white cannot simply eliminate this
Knight at an opportunity moment uh at
the moment black porn of course
defending it Black's Bishop also kind of
eyed up indirectly on G4 so I don't
think you can take twice on this square
but uh first of all for Aryan does he
just lash out now does he break out in
the center or does he sit is there
anything else productive to do well he
has also an idea just to go out with
Knight D7 to F6 I believe I'm not sure
E5 is so good
because uh
but E5 is also something completely that
you have to consider especially after B4
if there is a d takes e595 the C3 phone
can be vulnerable as well and after E5
if once the queen gets back on the d8 H4
diagonal the H4 Pawn can be attacked so
it is kind of dangerous for white also
and just as we say it uh Aryan plays it
uh I've had the luck to play around many
times analyzed study with him and yeah
he if given the opportunity he prefers
to be a bit more direct so E5 not too
surprising uh it's just about whether
that does kind of open the position in
White's favor Black's favor or pieces of
course on this board but that's about to
change I don't like very much what go
cash played in the last several moves
because uh if you play H4 I think you
have to make sure that it has
uh idea behind it and it was not Castle
something something is wrong though
after E5 it may be the case that black
is too active because now if black is
moving away the pawn and Bishop D6 can
trap The Rook
yeah let's show these moves on the board
all right this would be a huge mistake
for example
yeah so black has to
be careful very precise in this position
because it's getting really complicated
I mean look at the center what we have
in the game
so there has to be a lot of calculations
also with both colors
and also it's not really possible for
black to actually liquidate in the
center either say for instance e takes
D4 I think would be a not a great move
because white can actually even capture
back with the pawn on E3
so there's a there would be a big threat
of Bishop takes Knight and rookie one
and Queen 98 is Clumsy
absolutely yeah just to show this on the
board the black Queen's pretty much
trapped and black has to shed material
to save her so yeah good spot there yeah
I was having similar positions when in
the London system you break out with E5
and looks like so energetic and good but
it's not always the case that it's uh
it's uh really good
or even if you play it you have to be
really very precise on on the
continuation after this move so I don't
know is F5 is too much
wow four pawn attack Pawn Stone shoot it
um yeah it's possible why not you said a
why not say B throw those pawns forward
well maybe it's too dangerous
I I like it it looks scary it is with
both colors okay
I mean
the kind of Chess that we like to see
it's Fighting Chess and whilst the games
heat up it's time to take a quick break
but don't go too far because we have
Hikaru Nakamura giving us another
confession
well we're back everybody so of course
uh talking about all the games once
again Magnus Drew again shocker I look
pretty standard very very
straightforward boring game
um so Drews they're gonna play
Armageddon soon just looking at the
other games go cash obviously all in
attack pushing Harry the H Pawn and a la
Simon William Styles so that game is
going to heat up that should be an
exciting game for the fans who are
watching for sure what else do we have
there's one other game yeah Oliver
sanish just very normal just just
standard e45 with the Fiona kettle on
the king side so nothing really special
there the game has to develop and then
we come to the two big games which is
obviously Fabiano's game against Wesley
and my game against
um noderbeck now this positioning has
Notre back I will at least as far as I
can recall I hadn't seen this idea with
um with this whole rookie one so maybe
it's standard maybe I just missed
something I don't really know either way
but
um I had a choice between playing like
97 or trying to be a little bit more
aggressive trying to go from D6 C5 but
you know as I was thinking about the
position it doesn't really look like
it's there and the main point about the
position is that basically by moving
this Knight all over the board and this
is of course using computers you know
computers basically what they'll do is
they'll say if you don't care about
wasting time because what because your
opponent's pushing pawns and so I mean
when I go 97 it's probably not something
like C3 D5 I don't know like Bishop D3
Bishop F5 something along these lines
and I mean I think it's very likely
headed towards a draw pretty soon
um but I I it to me is somehow trying to
play D6 and leave the Knight on D5 in
this specific position just felt a
little bit dubious now I'm sure a
computer would say it's completely fine
you're insane for for moving the night
um because I could have also played like
D6 C6 and if white goes C4 I get Knight
B4 and A5 to lock the Knight on B4 as
opposed to just playing Knight and seven
and D5
um but it but again I was kind of
worried that I played some D6 there's
there's going to be something at some
point with like Bishop A3 and C4 and
maybe it's nothing but it just feels a
little bit a little bit dicey worth once
I go 97 I play D5 he's gonna have to
play C3 unless he goes C4 in one go and
then it's gonna go like D5 which is
about five the Bishops when we basically
play a standard rookie one Berlin
variation except White's pushed B3 and
A4 and I don't see any world where
having played B through an A4 can be
beneficial so to me that's why I'm
staying solid here rather than doing
anything insane again I mean I think
this game is going to Peter out very
soon
um unless Notre gets crazy I mean maybe
he can do something like G4 and try to
plan the king side take advantage of me
moving my knight so often but again I
don't really believe in it even G4
Knight C6 C3 D5 I mean with having
played G4 that creates a weakness for no
reason so I mean I'm not thrilled by it
and also to add to that the other reason
I'm not thrilled by it is Fabian was
very clearly in preparation in his game
he's used like five minutes Wesley's
deep in the tank um and it looks like a
standard fobby game where basically
Fabiano has probably looked at this like
move 70 I mean joking obviously but he's
probably looked at this for another 10
moves and I'm guessing that if Wesley's
not very precise in the next couple of
moves Wesley is going to be suffering
he's going to be down half an hour on
the clock and the tournament could just
be over
um today frankly because it just as I'm
looking that position this just feels
like a classic it just feels like a
classic fobby Supreme as as usual and um
it's unfortunate but it is what it is so
we'll see if Wesley can defend that game
then of course my game we'll see if
noderbeck tries to get creative or
whether it just Peter's out to draw in
the next half hour but ah shots I guess
as you as you would say so see you guys
foreign
[Music]
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps lordy Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023. Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long-time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and shakriya mamat
yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
hello and we are back in action and the
chess excitement continues for some more
hours and before the break or during the
break we had thought thoughts from
Hikaru he told us that Fabiano was in
Fabiano's Supreme mode he also said that
he felt that his own position was going
to Peter out into a draw so what do we
think about hikaru's thoughts is it
still true
well I believe that he's a little bit
uncomfortable position right now and he
wouldn't mind if it ended in a draw but
you could see that he was kind of
worried and so that well maybe for Fabi
he can squeeze and maybe there can be
some trouble for Wesley which I think is
kind of true but we have to see some
fantastic technique if Fabi would win
which uh it's clearly if Carolina
Nakamura was worried that it can be
already something that he will not have
to fight too much for tomorrow because
Fabi can finish the tournament yes
and David
we saw Hikaru not being particularly
optimistic about his chances yeah he's
uh yeah he's just playing down his own
expectations maybe he doesn't want to
put too much pressure on himself this
isn't the type of position where uh
Hikaru can just kind of gamble go all in
uh anything uh any winning attempts will
take huge huge risk so I think just
maybe more than one eye now on the
Carolina against whistly so game for him
and uh on the kind of bright side for
Hikaru Wesley so is great in these kind
of technical positions in these slower
drier end games so I think he might be
given a helping hand by Wesley a bit of
a favor there I don't have the feeling
that Wesley will lose that game against
Fabi I think that will go down to
Armageddon so it's just about Hikaru
whether he can do the business in his
own classical game and uh there is one
thing that does concern me about the
Wesley so Fabiano caruana encounter and
that's take a look at the discrepancy in
clock times I mean Fabiano has a huge
time advantage
yes he did not spend too much time on
this game yet probably it's also because
his preparation was very good as
Nakamura always takes the opportunity to
highlight that that his preparation is
incredible one of the best or maybe the
best in the world right now and
so
we'll see how we can manage
yeah and uh here for Wesley yes he's
down at 34 minutes but as we see on the
board it's so simplified right now it's
only a pair of Rooks and knights left on
the board that it feels like with two or
three accurate moves he'll be safe and
the rest he can play on some
automatically
it won't cost that much time on the
clock so the time differential you don't
take the time to the next game so Fabby
he might have five hours on the clock
but if your position isn't winning uh
you would take the full points do you
know I had that thought of uh you know
you getting allocated like x amount of
time for the whole tournament
but I think some players had this
thought that to have a certain amount of
time for the game and if it's a draw you
continue to play with that um what is it
the leftover and you continue until the
point uh some some of the wins I love
that idea just imagine you start a game
with five seconds on your clock yeah
there's definitely going to be a winner
by the end of that one
this sadly is and meanwhile Let's uh
talk about the game in front of us
Fabiano of course trying to win I don't
think there's any risk at all for white
white tonight was okay just until this
moment hitting a Pawn on A6 that has
been reacted to by Wesley so and this
does involve a bit of calculation
because white can give a check on B7 I'm
sure Wesley has that all calculated out
we should mention one interesting point
about uh 10 or 15 moves ago now Fabiano
did turn down the chance to repeat the
position uh it wouldn't have been the
third time but he was the one who kind
of broke out of that sequence so he was
the one who was playing for the win who
turned down the opportunity to likely
draw that game and I think Wesley uh
kind of slightly demoralized by that
that's uh kind of hence why Wesley's
been burning so much time on the clock
but what do we think here dude this must
be the creative black has in mind
because it seems like he's is he
sacrificing the pawn for activity
because after Knight B7 if we dive into
some moves black has to go I thinking
day seven because he has to defend the
C7 Pawn that's what I would believe and
if after King D7
Knight takes A5
if you're okay then B4
looks like you're winning the pawn back
but B4 shuts the door holds on to this
Knight and is still a pawn
I think one question might be whether
this end game is drawn for example
Knight to C4 uh trying to trade off
these Knights and whether you can hold
this but this is miserable you're
pulling down as black
[Music]
Fight for Your Life yeah
as far as I understand King E4 even some
idea going King F5 King G6 at some point
I mean this is not exactly
you want you want to play against
Fabiano even though if you're going to
make a draw I don't think it can it is
so easy
and what about the Alternatives Knight
B7 track as you say it's likely the King
goes back we take
what else can black try I'm struggling
um I just assume he's got it all
calculated out because it's Wesley so
but you can see on the camera Wesley is
deep in concentration maybe he's
doubting himself maybe he's just double
checking his variations in his mind
could you leave that night sidelined and
actually step forward with your own Pawn
to B4 with the idea that then you step
over to Rook A8 yeah yeah B4 is
something I I would also think but
several ideas to to work with with white
A3 I can go and after okay hrx takes
takes Rook A8 Rook C5 or just to play B3
yeah they are nitrook C5
holds the pawn you said B3 as well in
this position just dropping the Knight
back maybe yeah and dropping back to C4
or Knight B7 and to C5
Black Knight can be stationed on D5
which can be very nice and the B4 Pawn
is holding up the a pawn
for the moment but still Pawn up is a
pawn up right I mean it's better if we
have the extra opponent not the opponent
that does kind of hint that Fabi in this
position I mean if you don't play note
p7 this opportunity will disappear uh
black will simply push the pawn to save
square like A4 so if there's no risk
attached you take the pawn you should
kind of ask your opponent if they have a
compensation if they've worked it out
yeah I think there is no other way for a
while then to take the pawn but maybe
Fabiano got surprised on this A5 and
he's trying to figure out first what is
really behind the A5
is it only activity what the Wesley has
in mind or is there any something
concrete
the evaluation bar still isn't impressed
at all I saw a featured chat a few
minutes ago saying it's impressive these
players can keep the game at 0.0 just
the whole the whole time but yeah here's
the first kind of puzzling confusing
moment because black kids are born down
after all and not winning it back
immediately it must be the word activity
you mentioned uh Judith just how that's
the big question could you get active
with the Rook rookie one hmm go behind
maybe try to hit this Pawn try to go for
this Pawn later
at the same time the question is where
are you heading to
if white just drops back maybe with the
Knights
I'm gonna come back around I'm
protecting this Pawn
maybe more kind of in under Judith's uh
kind of line sorry not uh Rook A8 here
but first V4
in this position and if B3 maybe now we
come behind
still I don't know where I'm going as
you say
yeah I want to Checkmate the white king
Knight on D5 push the pawn
I'm glad you said Checkmate the king
because it suddenly occurred to me that
White's King isn't necessarily that
secure so maybe like we can start with
the Knight on A5 The Rook goes back to
E8
so this position yeah so yeah is there
any way that black can
play for mate play for mate
it would require pushing either the F or
H pawns pushing the black G Pawn so
that's two moves yeah exactly three
moves 95 close the door on the white
king and then four so it's four moves so
you
I don't know unfortunately it feels like
white has time to escape I can just push
this pawn and there's already Escape
Route for the king if you start off with
F5 for instance
maybe The Rook can go Pawn hunting
already
and the evaluation bar is really not
approving of my attempts to make sense
of Wesley's sacrifice well if something
I think then not F5 but H5 if you want
to play for some Checkmate ideas which
seems to be not not executable
there's Rook C5 anyway and G5 probably
right can just capture on B5
show this yeah well I couldn't just
ignore the threats if you give a check
the white king simply has one safe
Square hand that's enough two pawns up
now uh hitting this Pawn as well
so no Checkmate attacks for black so if
we go back I think black should be
thinking about activity and if you see
it very nicely it should and Knight B7
on the board that somehow black wants to
get his Knight to D5 that's the place it
deserves to be
but the question will be whether does it
worse is it worth giving up a pawn for
this I'm very curious if Rook C8 Knight
C4 the idea used told yeah is behind it
or B4 I would go B4 I think
uh before it's too late don't allow that
white knight to get anchored your moment
of truth will Wesley push that black
pawn will you play rookie eight hit the
White Knight oh he's answered very
quickly rookie eight
and said yeah well he must be planning
Knight C4 and having enough confidence
in holding this position upon down
and for a moment there Fabiano didn't
look too happy he kind of looked away
from the board kind of scratched his
head he's like oh maybe he's going to
hold a draw by force that's always the
most frustrating thing when you're
grinding away slowly making progress and
your opponent finds kind of a direct
path but it didn't look obvious and of
course it's a big Temptation and a great
wish for a player like Fabiano did today
if he wins
you can just say that we are done and
before the last round he would most
likely be the winner as uh Nakamura has
a position which is
um worse a little bit worse or very
uncomfortable to play so it's temptation
to fight for it how to win this game how
to win this game and the good thing is
that it's only him who can fight for a
win so this is a very ideal situation
for uh for a tournament leader
before on the board
those lights are going to get traded off
inevitable the knights will disappear
it's a rook end game white will be a
pawn up
but it's interesting again it's just
another example where you see the top
players they just hate to be in a
passive situation and sit there and wait
until your opponent is squeezing you and
torture you and and playing for your
weaknesses and there are so many
examples where simply in this kind of
situations you give up material in order
to get back the activity and to try to
get the compensation for the sacrifice
material yeah always defend actively I
think that's that's the key that's the
thing we learned from these elite
players though nowadays maybe it's less
since we have the engines and the
engines love extra material and even
they go for Passive play many times but
but still I believe most of the the
ghost players they they always prefer
activity uh
then and sacrifice something for it yeah
I would say actually that's where
Technologies revolutionized it engines
used to be obsessed with material until
the last two three years or at least
until uh yeah recent times and now
actually when I analyze with them if
there's a forcing move it's always the
top one if there's a way to defend
actively it's always kind of chosen so
yeah it's it's kind of what Wesley's
trying to do here it's
whether it works or not I'm looking at
the bar I'm thinking okay it works but
I'm still surprised he's going for it so
confidently so quickly there Wesley so
because it looks like white will win a
pawn White's King will be active
I think we'll have to wait to find out
whether he's successful in his defensive
efforts
yeah I agree with you there David let's
check out the bird's eye view and have a
look at the other games in progress
and a lot of exciting things have
happened I mean I can see that in the
game between farrugia and Anish giri the
tension in the center has resolved and
the Knight has appeared on F5 which as
we all know Knight on F5 will thrive
and good cash has entrenched a knight on
C6
which one looks like there's going to be
more fireworks
I would be happy to visit the alireza
Anish game okay let's go there and you
have to remember both of these players
according to our resident statistician
Thai Bruce Zimmerman says that uh they
have 0.1 percent chance of winning the
tournament
0.1 that's uh not a great amount
but it means it is not all lost but I
can say that this is the wonderful when
we see top players still being
interested in the competition when they
practically have no chance to succeed
though both of these players I'm pretty
sure they were toying with the idea that
well it would be nice to win the
tournament and for both of them it would
be possible Right it wouldn't be
something that people would be surprised
completely so for them obviously they
feel that they wanted more out of this
tournament but this is a situation that
they are not going to be fighting for
the first place but still they are
fighting it out and we see a very
interesting position and I'm surprised
that alireza was able to reach out to F5
because if I know this then I will take
white before
I didn't realize that he will have
enough time to reach this destination
with this Knight yeah so one strong
piece here for white Judy it's enough to
attract you here it's enough to you
think give me attacking chances long
term yeah for white it's just the queen
on C2 is misplaced let's face it needs
to be on the king side on F3 or at some
point if the Knight can move away the
only problem is for a white if knight
from D2 moves away with the idea Bishop
A6 and queen D2 that the black most
likely plays places his Knight on B3 and
he covers very important squares from
the Queen the D2 and C1
yeah that's very annoying and
okay here the big question for uh
farooges how to improve his pieces uh
like you say kind of centralizing a rook
is one move
um and if you can't get your queen into
the game
do you have to try now it feels awkward
it feels clumsy but going back to square
one retreating pieces we've seen it
today well I think now there are quite a
few options for white for example first
of all white can go G5 time to time
which I think would be probably early
but for example what about playing King
H2 moving away the bishop and then Rook
G1 G5 idea
looking H1 I don't know where exactly I
would rather have the king because of
course it has Pros cons on both move but
maybe King H1 so there are quite several
attacking ideas for the future for white
yeah let's jump in and share some of
those ideas we have one of the world's
greatest attackers here so I want to
make use of that I want to learn a few
things for King H1 wow
threatening or hinting at Rook G1 G5
let's say yeah I'm not hiding very much
my idea let's say I make a move then
suddenly root G1 Eric G1 now you're
running two moves away from blowing open
the king side
oh I would start to get scared I do feel
that Black's maybe main idea is to play
cc4 yeah exactly and eliminate my
attacker on E3 just before you get ideas
of trying to sacrifice around my king
trying to break it open uh maybe for
example in the current position that's
kind of a small positional threat to
play C4 get these Bishops off
but how to prevent that I don't see a
way yeah this like you said Jude it's
just so annoying to put it on the board
Knight to B3 hitting the rook and this
White Queen now is kind of in a way
trapped just no way to get active
hmm
this is the current position
I would just be lazy and play Rook D1
but seems to be one of the most or maybe
the most logical move but black is going
to go Rook this Rook d8 yeah well C4 on
the board
he beat me to it I was just just as I
said Rook D1 I was like wait C4 just if
black side is C4 we should play C4 it
also crossed my mind to be honest but I
I don't know to have this D4 Square
uh weakness it it can be tricky
and of course B4 is something I would
consider at first with black
yeah if B4 happens then black has great
potential long term on the queen side uh
also this uh this Knight might
re-centralize reposition itself rotate
around to D4 beautiful Outpost but at
least now
this bishop suffice and yeah I mean
we've seen several games in this
tournament where there was badly placed
A7 bishop or A2 Bishop right and this is
exactly another example where it might
be the case that the bishop on A7
is gonna suffer there for a long time
without becoming reasonable with placed
let's say the bishop on f8 would be now
already a much better placement
yeah teleport we need it
would defend everything yeah so maybe
there's some danger here for example if
white does ever kind of get the Rook
across Knight F3 take and drop the queen
back Black's King lacks Defenders takes
a few moves but certainly might have
that time if things block up does uh
Anish have anything more powerful here
to kind of release the tension
this position
after C4 I mean there's the option of
taking but it feels wrong positionally
and maybe dynamically
yeah B Tech C4 is kind of to something
to consider right and after Knight C4
Knight B3 and Knight D4 Maybe
let's come around
somehow it feels wrong just this white
knight is so nice maybe we kind of play
around a night on D4 if it ever lands
but
yeah both sides have beautiful Knights
now it's just I don't know what to do
next or or maybe Queen D2 enter to D6 on
Knight B3
yeah that's a clever uh clever idea
Queen D2 you could always kind of sneak
around with your Banker's idea maybe as
well C4 is on the board oh wow
okay we take C4 played by anishagiri
anti-positional breaking his Pawn
structure but he didn't want uh the
position to lock up
after Knight C4 maybe black and just
take on C4 and start pushing uh start
putting pressure on the B2 phone playing
Rook B8
yeah quite likely maybe just peace
trades just even if you kind of worsen
your structure maybe that's the name of
the game right now
and I think one at one point I think
Rook will stand on ae6 so whenever a
white wants to make all these Bishop H6
things it would be a great defender over
there
the work truly wants to stand on D4
though I just have a feeling none of
them but we have two Rooks
yeah automatic sacrifice there but
meanwhile still so tense
I wonder if Magnus would still pick
black
if given the option
yeah this one I have a feeling there'll
be a winner I just don't know who it
will be and I think a Time scramble as
well is guaranteed we're running at move
20 now and both players down below the
hour mark already
I'm curious is it possible to play na
Rook D1
just to keep it the way it is and are
you going to defend the pawn on C4 or
would you be protecting it
yeah let's uh jump in and ask that
question Rook D1
so the question is to defend or not to
defend I don't really want to put my
Bishop on the E6 Square now that you've
said I should use my Rook for that
square
well I don't know but you know what is
my plan with white
is to go Knight B1 and C3 wow
that is another level of sophistication
if I have enough time but it makes uh
the B2 pawning very weak well it's not
Knight B1 which makes it very weak it's
Weak by itself
it was not me
I defend it with rookie too I thought
Bishop C1 sometimes retrieved you never
know yeah yeah
yeah for example Queen oh I can't really
attack it actually I was gonna say queen
B6 Queen B7 but I'm going to walk into
some
uh nasty but I think you can leave it
right you can first first of all
reinforce the last word
uh sure I wanted to hold on to C4
so for instance maybe use the time to go
Bishop E6 since you can't take one
A4 because the B2 Pawn drops let's say
the White Knight comes out yeah and now
dude Judith's idea of night beef
like B3 and then
dick the Knight on D4 yeah beautiful
home for that piece yeah yeah that's
that's the the the key counter play I
think for black to have it on D4 but in
the meantime we have a move Knight takes
C4
he doesn't want to be material down
ferrugia and I said it to the two of you
in the break I'm just getting so many
flashbacks of a game I had against Rouge
in that game it was basically the same
Pawn structure he also played C4 at some
moment and I later blundered and Knight
takes H6 tactic so watch out for that
one to happen a bit later in the game
but now black will be fighting some way
or another to push the queen back from
C4 and play C4 himself the question is
how to implement it
you need to kick the queen away that's
step one then you need to push your Pawn
forward step two then you need to trade
off the dark squared Bishop step three
and you're safe but but for now you
cannot play Bishop E6 because Queen
takes A4 will be the reaction yeah so
probably don't want to go Bishop B6 to
waste time so some Rook B8
and maybe Rook B8 and Bishop B5 with the
idea later C4
yeah Step One is the hardest one to
achieve so maybe root beer looks natural
to me
it's not actually easy to defend the b
or B2 Pawn
yes but the White Queen will come to C1
yeah and threatened Bishop takes Pawn
yeah for example if Rook ABA then maybe
white can just in fact after Rook AB8
can you
they can just take it immediately the
only thing is that after Bishop H6 let's
show this on the board
yeah
also happen now
I just played it's a Quincy one
or Rook D1 because I would love to have
my Rook uh first on the D file and only
after that to bring my queen back all
the sacrifices in the air I'll show you
what happens if I take this Pawn now
Judah are you generous you can take that
pawn like and are you gonna take and
take the Lego Bishop takes H6
immediately or come Queen C1 first
you won first
Quincy one hitting this rook and now
I'll just for argument's sake I'll play
a move like Rook B3
I know that's probably not the best one
but just to let you show your idea
Bishop takes H6 right well we're gonna
grab it yeah I don't know if it's good
but we're gonna grab it looks good and I
can eliminate your knight for example
now
I take it but let's show what happens
here I guess you jump in with the queen
I can take this Knight but
oh maybe that was even stronger Rick
takes Bishop oh Ivanka Rook takes Bishop
yeah oh I should have taken that night
just to show now it's Unstoppable Queen
and night combo Checkmate guaranteed
unless black Parts with the queen
nice tactics yeah there were always
there was always that move in the air as
well so oh a lot of danger after you
mentioned like you fell foul love this
bishop takes H6 I was like oh that's the
way forward and the worst thing is in
that game against Russia from two years
ago I was always looking at like Bishop
takes H6 every move Bishop takes H6
Bishop takes H6 the one time I forgot to
calculate he played Knight takes H6 and
he managed to beat me and Judith maybe
that's why your Rook ad1 move by
Instinct uh could be quite nice to at
some point eliminate this bishop to
ensure this white knight survives until
a bit later on also to point out if
black ever takes this knight uh for
example here white will get fantastic
positional compensation by taking with
the pawn and this bishop is Unleashed
oh yeah on the long diagonals that's
still nice to be true for white
yeah yeah so yeah interesting moments
for Asia lining up the sacrifices
okay and on that note I think it's the
perfect time to go to the bird's eye
view and check out some of the other
games because I see action is about to
explode in quite well another game I
have my eye on which is the gukash
against orientare because take a look at
all those beautiful pawns wow in the
center that is uh full-on tensioned
that is the definition of tension all of
the pawns there the whole white and
black Army staring down at each other
almost uh yeah invading now for white
this white knight is a bit stuck but at
the moment it will cost black a couple
of moves to take it
I think white wants to play E4 next move
just to create the Symmetry with the
quality in the center
this is wild where to even start to
where to even start calculating
well captures
captures and threats
I mean it sounds so basic but I mean
it's so true I mean you've got to
practice all your tactics and all this
way of thinking so much so that it
becomes automatic like our friend Judith
I've noticed
for you you've practiced it so long and
for certainly so many years that those
are your first instincts yes absolutely
and of course in such a position you
have to take something right you cannot
just leave it there it's either you
start with Bishop C6 or take with C
takes the C takes D4 or E takes D4 and
the problem is that you have to start
with one of them and then go on with the
others and sometimes it's a problem when
you have little time and actually the
time is running down for Atari he only
has 37 minutes by now
it it does make a difference whether
what your intuition says where to start
because in this way you can you can
spend and eat up your time so easily
that you start calculating this I don't
like it then I try the other one I don't
like it then you don't go all the way
you try the next one and then you just
start to be confused
yeah four logical captures well
basically if you think about it Bishop
C6 I think it can be eliminated fast
because B takes C6 if we can jump into
some lines
and there I think black would lose
material takes takes takes on C6 C takes
D5 and black cannot capture it back
because of Bishop F3 right
and if this is bad for black then it
means that after C takes D5 you have to
move away white has
a bishop pair and also sometimes to take
on G4 and actually capture a pawn so
this I would not like to look further
for a moment so let's rule out yeah
because let's see if others are even
worse or not
so right now DTX C4
latex C4 I also don't like because D5
can happen I think there is a huge
Advantage certainly the C6 knight ever
never will be able to take it in good
circumstances and after this Knight C4
so that would be a huge Advantage for
white let's just point out Queen takes
Pawn walks into a nasty night Fork oh
yeah
it also means just by looking at this
tactic that white is actually
threatening porn takes Pawn
exactly the starting position suddenly
we have uh an answer to where to begin
yes absolutely
and and then we have to take a look see
takes and E takes which which actually
also doesn't look good so after
[Laughter]
now black is in a big big question what
to do yeah in this position just to show
all of the options here
anytime a pawn lands on D5 it looks like
black is just completely busted white is
winning because of this Knight check
this night Fork so why does the
evaluation bar in the start position say
that uh black is doing okay it looks
like
every capture that we've seen so far
leads in White's favor and Bishop takes
Knight eventually after a long long
think there from ariantari maybe this
was the best of the bad bunch
and the key is whether he can find a
different move a different alternative
what about playing here Knight F6 can
black goes something like that aha
so not taking this Pawn because of the
variation we showed just to put that on
the board again and disaster on the long
diagonal instead maybe just moving
and getting ready to capture on the
Square with a knight
I really want to play E4 I know it's
probably not a good move
to stare down I think it's a great move
put it on the board I mean it doesn't
change the evaluation too much that's
the final move that's the fun move but
maybe not the best move
what could be good for white hair but
you know what maybe after Bishop G4
Knight G4 E4 oh trade-off and maybe now
just a cement a Pawn on the D5 Square
this would be aesthetically just
beautiful and look this Pawn is going to
decide the game long term
I mean these two are gonna run
I really don't envy Ariane right now it
feels like he's under a lot of pressure
this is the current position he spent a
long time I'm sure it takes C6 and no
immediate follow-up
he's got to do something about this
Knight unless he's getting ready to
sacrifice do you think he can take on D4
when he takes D4 you mean well can I
Enlighten you guys I checked the
computer I've checked the Oracle and the
Oracle says there's only one way for
Ariane to survive these complications
and he has to take the pawn
but the key is to not take the second
Pawn so take the three pawns to take I'm
assuming yes it's Queen takes C6 sorry
yeah I should have been clearer and
after C takes D5 step back with the
queen to C7 B7 oh B7 2K but whether
that's
let me check for you whether it has to
be B7 no any Queen Retreat is fine how
do you minimizes the damage well maybe
objectively is fine but still there is
going to be a huge fight for example I
want to take it on E5 I believe
then uh probably Bishop B5 is the best
right okay just to trade off everything
let's say a position like this one or
maybe you take with the other night I'm
not sure maybe the other night
yeah yeah still tense looks like a
grinfeld kind of now just white has a
very strong Pawn uh but black has active
pieces
well this is gonna be a huge battle and
it's very dangerous for black you have
to play really the most precise moves
and having 32 minutes for the rest of
the game it's not making it easy
we're only a move 16 even before he gets
the 10 second increment he needs to make
24 moves now Ariane actually this is his
16th so 25 moves in 31 minutes just over
one minute per move on average
difficult
difficult times yeah it is a difficult
position for Ariane and on that note
let's go back to the bird's eye view and
have a look at the games
so one thing I I can see immediately
from the alireza farouza Anish giri is
that basically you guys have been
completely right in your prediction it
was as you've actually said and the game
that I would like to kind of check out
is that of course no debug against a
Hikaru because Hikaru is beginning to
just minimally turn things in his favor
and I'm only saying this because he's
actually bearing down on the C3 Pawn
now we haven't been at this game in a
while uh last we were here we said okay
maybe Hikaru under some slight pressure
but should be roughly balanced and this
is the position we see in front of us a
lot of minor pieces have disappeared a
set of Pawns have disappeared Ivanka you
mentioned some
hope some pressure along the C file but
white is tied down now defending this
Pawn
what do we think the remaining pieces
this black Bishop is very very passive
but it holds everything together White's
Bishop not necessarily that impressive
yeah now that the board is in full
screen I've changed my mind
primarily because the B7 Pawn is also
weak
also a Target here this looks almost
identical to A variation of the Petrov
defense where it's kind of just
maintaining the status quo black has
pressure on the C file white has
pressure on the B file and neither side
can really make progress
uh Judith who would you pick here
be worried that much playing with black
I believe
yeah I'm not happy to have the E6 Bishop
on the same square uh same diagonal as
all the other pawns like on the white
square
I have these spawns but the C3 is really
weak so
I'm not sure black has to worry so much
though Rook B3 can be the next move
uh
for white and put pressure on the B7 at
first it doesn't look so bad for black
but white can press
black has one trick at his disposal for
instance say you step forward with your
king
G7 and then Rook B3 I just wanted to
highlight that you can play B6 yeah
let's put this on the board if black
does play a move like King G7 also just
genuinely a useful move sometimes you
want to play rookie H4 go for the attack
if given the time but
you read my mind just to put your other
idea on the board of anchor uh if white
does attack this Pawn black could always
react if necessary by pushing forward
and here let's say if everything gets
traded off then the C3 Pawn drops at the
end and this would just be close to a
draw
so it feels like even if things go wrong
for Hikaru they can't go too badly wrong
just about whether he can hope for more
than this level looking endgame
yeah anything more to add here it looks
very balanced to me
there's a is a good idea probably white
would be playing on uh and King G7 is on
the board so after Rook B3
the question is actually after rugby
three the A5 Pawn would be hanging so
Queen B7 was not even a threat
I mean B2
C4 is might be the idea actually oh wow
is this a draw offer from Hikaru he's
just gone forward with his King to G7
then he's gone back with his King uh
like you said Judith the White Queen was
indirectly maybe hinting at some
discovered attacks later on well
actually it was not true because after
c4d takes C4 D5 C3 was possible but
maybe Hikaru just thinks that uh nothing
can be done with white but sometimes
it's really nice to kind of gauge
whether your opponent is happy with the
draw
hmm
just asking the question exactly and
then once you've got your answer you can
then decide for yourself although having
said all that judging from hikaru's body
language it does look like Hikaru
is resigned to
a draw but also it's it's a
psychological thing that the Hikaru
probably wanted to say that okay I'm
okay with the draw are you and then if
he starts naughty black starts to push
it then maybe he will have this mindset
that I have to win if Hikaru wants a
draw I should try it and this is what
Hikaru wants that the white is starts to
play maybe more aggressive though it's
it's not so easy to play aggressive here
with white
but there are two weaknesses of white
right C3 and A5
well interesting moment in this game
will it fizzle out into a draw
immediately
maybe it will maybe it won't but I think
this is the perfect time to take a break
and of course I have to mention that it
is don't miss your chance to win Diamond
membership this Friday the chess.com
Discord server is hosting an arena with
four Diamond memberships up for grabs to
stake your claim join the Discord at
go.chess.com forward slash Discord then
head over to go.chess.com forward slash
connect and connect your account and
you're done you can now compete in the
weekly arena for our Discord community
and win free Diamond membership use
x-clam Discord in chat now and we'll be
back soon but don't go anywhere things
are heating up and the action will be
back right after this
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki and
Josh Toth everyone's favorite social
media troll known as Anish Geary and so
many more chessable can help you raise
your game to the next level you're
getting started on the fundamentals you
should check out everyone's first chess
workbook
maybe you want to stop letting all those
points slip away in the end game 100 end
games you must know is the course for
you
did you not notice your king was in
check and still can't figure out why the
pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome back and I hope you're
ready for all the action that is going
to be coming your way today and that we
see Anish giri and Ali Reza farooza in
deep thought as they figure out all the
complexities in their game but in the
other hand in the break we actually had
a result and if we go back to the bird's
eye view we can see there is oh there is
a half half there oh it's a new board
set up because it was a draw between
Fabiana caruana and Wesley so
so David tell us exactly what happened
in the end yeah in the end the game
between Fabiano caruana and Wesley so
did end in a repetition of moves as we
mentioned Carolina was a pawn up but
Wesley held it very very uh kind of
resourcefully there and this is the
position we last left this game just to
show how things ended black did indeed
drop the Knight into C4 forcing the
trade of knights here and despite the
fact that white is a pawn up he was not
able to make progress he started with G4
maybe hoping to sneak in with the white
king a bit later on but Black's King was
first towards the center King D6 and
after a trade of Pawns here first a
check a very important check actually
from Wesley so this was the annoying
move Rook takes A2 and white simply
cannot Advance because his own pawns are
dropping
after this Fabiana decided okay Safety
First was needed his King dropped back
to defend those pawns and C6 King F3 we
saw that white is simply stuck white is
frozen here because he needs to keep his
B4 and D4 pawns defended with his Rook
he needs to keep the other pawns
defended with his King and there's no
way to make progress after G3 the
position repeated itself King D5 and a
dance between the rook and king The Rook
steps back the king steps forward and
this game did fizzle out with straight
to Armageddon well I'm very impressed by
the defensive skills Wesley so showed in
this game I mean he was just smelled it
that it can be so dangerous that he's
just ready to give up a pawn and look
for counter play and look at that in the
final position black has The Rook on B2
which is the best place for the rook in
such an end game attacking on the second
rank the F2 and from the back attacking
the B4 pawn and this way black can hold
the draw without any difficulties
yeah just impressive he had to foresee
this set up just 10 moves ago when he
sacrificed that pawn but it was the most
efficient way and he got the result he
desired Fabiano now he'll hold the lead
but that lead might diminish
it might diminish and especially when
you think that Hikaru Nakamura who is in
second place is trailing him by two
points
well
what do we think about Fabiano's chances
in Armageddon he he did win one game but
he also lost on Tuesday against kukash
although he had a great position
uh well as as he's in great form in this
tournament
I would say that he has better chances
okay he has better chances I think
although thinking back Fabiano he's got
one out of two Armageddon Wesley so
quick so solid
yeah I don't know I'll say Wesley just
to spice up the tournament standings
what about you I'm gonna agree with
David I think Wesley is very fast and
also incredibly solid when he wants to
be
okay so let's uh review the other games
in Play
well not your back for example still
trying to when it was very clearly said
silently by Nakamura that he's ready for
a draw because he started to move the
king when his optimal position was Queen
on C7 and Rook on C8 he started to play
with the King to G8 and G7 kind of
offering a draw but no their back still
tries to maneuver around with his queen
and the Rook
but is this also a draw offer from
nordeback because I'm sure I've seen
that Queen do a dance it went to B5 B2
E2 B5 and then back again a little
triangle there we can draw here yvanka
the White Queen has been using these
three squares and here I expect Nakamura
to just move his queen as well no need
to allow white to get ambitious and kind
of plant a queen in the center of the
board and controlling things no need to
change things up too much either so yeah
for the same time I think for another
brick it's a very nice feeling that
here's the boss he's playing he's gonna
he is going to be deciding whether he's
ready for a draw or not so he can still
maneuver around put the queen on E3 put
it back going here going there maybe he
wants to place his Rook later on to B5
or now he wants to go Queen B2
you know maneuvering and when it seems
like you're just making moves it's not
always the in reality that you're just
making moves sometimes you can just
improve little by little and go on the
nerves of your opponent also just go
round and round and round till they get
dizzy they lose their bearings that's
what he's trying to do nodded back
in fact I I heard that was a technique
that's often used by Grand Masters they
make a lot of nothing moves
that forces their opponents to think and
then they switch Tack and play something
aggressive at the very last minute well
karpov did it many times generally
speaking especially in a drawish end
games in the fifth or sixth hour
unfortunately I was also experiencing
this this is going this way that way you
try to play fast but still you're
spending your time and then when you're
alone time then he does something
that is is annoying or or he just went
wrong and you lost the thread anyway
already by that time yeah I know a lot
of top players they take inspiration
from tennis it's like you're having a
rally you just kind of slowly putting
the ball back and forth back and forth
suddenly you hit a harder shot the
faster shot your opponent just can't
react in time and that's uh what you
have to do in these types of slower
positions just change the pace keep them
guessing and I don't expect Nakamura to
crack but it's nice to see uh how do
sator of playing on
no fear despite having a tough
tournament in the last few rounds
so we're expecting
the equilibrium to be maintained here
should we go check out some other games
yes I'm glad that you use the word
equilibrium because there's a position
I'm dying to revisit which looks like
there is no equilibrium at all and it's
the one with between good cash and
arihan
but if we talk about other game between
alireza and Annie she's the same story
it's just it's crazy complicated okay
which one we have no no we go to go cash
because that's really important moves
has happened since we visited last
yeah important moves but we were able to
predict some of them go cash going for
the beauty price going for Glory by
throwing his E Pawn forward as well uh
let's just jump in and backtrack one
move because it was a vital move and uh
here we saw instead of taking the pawn
actually keeping the balance here
objectively ariantari did crack under
the pressure and Knight F6 branded with
a question mark not the best move making
his position worse and that was partly
because of this one a stunner Pawn to E4
and we had the standoff we had the
Face-Off between black sports white
spawns as you suggested it previously he
wanted to have this three pawns just
there c4d4 E4 opposite
to C5 D5 E5 Pawns
wrestling in the center
I would have liked to have seen like
yukash's face when he made that move and
also arya's reaction like would have
been like whoa
what is this what have I done at this
point he's so used to kakash throwing
pawns forward look at this kind of
straggler on C6 locked Behind Enemy
Lines that I think Arian would have
expected this and he did meet this with
Knight takes E4 but now wow click uh
click here how do you miss it quick
flurry of moves C takes D5 really nice
one here and it must be in this position
that kukesh has something strong
so much tension which Knight to capture
first of all whether to pin this Knight
against the black queen
well I would think Knight takes E4 and
D5
passports
looks so tempting looks really visually
striking here
black support up but who cares about the
number of points it's about how far
Advanced they are and he's heading
straight down this line dude and
importantly The White Square Bishop is
right there for white so Bishop A6 can
be a continuation supporting the C6 pass
spawn or just to play Bishop F3 but of
course uh we'll see how strong are these
uh double pass spawn connected post
spawns how do you even stop the spawn
running forward after a move like Bishop
to F3 black has to rely on some tactics
uh we should mention that this is not
quite a threat yet it looks like what is
about to win a piece with F3 and forking
The Black Queen at night but F3 is met
by a queen check so
black can ignored that one temporarily
but yeah it's the pawns it's all about
the pawns we're Assuming he's going to
go for this uh actually Ariane has
paused after Knight takes Knight not
automatically recapturing yes because
it's not tempting to allow white to get
this star spawns but it seems like there
is nothing better
yeah after a bit of thought Queen takes
Knight down to 25 minutes now and it's
only the halfway mark before they reach
the golden move 40 where they do get a
10 second increment and D5 instantly
from gokesh
this is a lesson in creating and
maintaining passports so far
totally
but to suggest a move for Ariane
is I'm trying
but C7 and Bishop A6 is also such a huge
threat at the same time after C7 Bishop
A6 C8 is still not the big threat the
big threat is to go move on with the
other Pawn D6 and possibly pushing to D7
and that is the painful thing for black
the question is whether can he go some
kind of contigence
playing F5 F4 at some point
it's kind of a panic reaction I
understand
but maybe I should do something like
that yeah it makes sense if you can
start counter-striking against the white
king then you have to go for it I mean
one question is whether white just
continues and ignores or does white
react if you push forward the promise
this bishop now is a bit stuck I don't
know whether you can drop back I don't
know whether you take this Knight but
either way at least you're creating some
confusion here for black it feels like
F5 must be on the cards if not you have
to move one of the two Rooks and just
hope that you put them on good squares
but wherever you go you might get hit by
those advancing foot soldiers
mm-hmm difficult position for black
and actually even if you look go Rook d8
already immediately C7 can be a killer
D5 Bishop F3 yeah
all the targets kebabed on this diagonal
Rook takes the queen and wow you can
even just take this back with a rope
and once you take this Black Brook next
move you make a new Queen yourself David
look at here the bishop bear I talk
about it too much dude that's all I ever
talk about the bishop pair and it's uh
that pair reigning Supreme right now
in the car position Knight takes Knight
and D5 on the board
for Ariane when it rains it pours
maybe we can zoom out
and take a look the other Reza game
because that's also something where oh
fiery stuff
and the time is ticking and alireza went
down to under 22 minutes while Anish
also has 33 left only
foreign
material Judith just no fear he's
creating chaos and he's forced Anish
into a mistake look at this question
mark attached to anishagiri's last move
a mistake making his position worse it
seems like he had an opportunity missed
opportunity what has happened to him
yeah should we do an action replay
quickly I think we have to
I'm very curious how the exchange was
sacrificed yeah so we left it in this
position black has just attacked the
White Queen and rather than retreating
we were looking in this direction going
the whole way back maybe sacrificing on
H6 he simply took a pawn walking into a
double attack here walking into a fork
Bishop to B3 hits The Rook hits the
queen and he was happy to Simply step
away gaining the black Bishop we talked
about sacrificing a rook for this bishop
in other variations to ensure that this
white knight survives forever the White
Queen as well on a nice kind of line
here threatening all sorts of checks uh
all sorts of attacks Knight takes porn
for example this was met by rookie six
you predicted this type of thing
happening a while ago Judith uh Queen
back Rook takes porn Bishop F1 about to
step onto the newly vacated light Square
diagonal and Rook e to B6 is the mistake
apparently black maybe with an objective
small Advantage but so difficult to
navigate these chaotic positions yeah
exciting but something even more
exciting is about to occur it is going
to be our second Armageddon game of the
round we are going to see Fabiana
caruana fighting off against Wesley so
Fabiana Carolina has 10 minutes on the
clock Wesley has only seven but it is
Fabiano in a must win situation and he
opens with D4
the biggest question is where will
Fabiano caruana deviate he was deep in
preparation in the previous game between
these two and wow it's uh Wesley who
deviates now it's the Queen's Gambit
declined I was thinking okay Wesley got
a good solid position out of the first
game he managed to draw quite
quite impressively with black but now he
switched it up dude I think he's more of
a player who likes to surprise the
opponent obviously it's not a surprise
because Fabiano had to be prepared for
this in the classical game to start with
but still I'm also on that side that I
rather switch
I mean especially in speeches yeah I
mean I mean if I'm prepared I know that
the opening I would rather switch
the game and this is topical stuff of
course the Queen's government decline
appeared in the recent world
championship match it's entered a lot of
top players repertoires just recently
because black is really flexible move
order doesn't matter so much you will
survive the opening Ivanka you're an
expert on this line yourself as black
sometimes it is my answer sometimes I
play this very well sometimes I get
tricked and there we see Wesley
initiating exchanges very early on this
is one of Black's approaches in order to
release the light squared Bishop so
general rule of thumb is that Bishop on
C8 can get out or has a role then black
is doing okay
if not then black suffers this black
Bishop is the key can he get it out and
right now there's a lot of tension in
the center this Black Knight looks nice
and strong but white is ready to
eliminate that piece with the bishop and
drop back with the white knight I think
Fabiano he's planted his Rooks on these
Central squares because he will want to
open things up given the opportunity for
white
but very tense right now Wesley has one
move before any action happens
how best to use it
and he backs up his Knights
so Knight E5 will be on the board I
guess yeah and then F3 E4 in the later
stage
yeah very shortly maybe it will happen
in the next few moves and Wesley brings
this bishop out first of all
okay so at least getting ready to trade
off some pieces if white does start
stepping forward in the center
well now also Knight E2 makes a lot of
sense I think with the threat of F3 if
you want to save the Knight or playing
immediately F3 that's also quite uh
energetic
goes for the immediate F3 forcing a
trade here another question is do you
take Black's Bishop with your own bishop
or do you take back the Black Knight
which is the most important minor piece
he takes the Knight and now white is
immediately ready to recapture and
stepping forward in the center it's
going to happen in the next move or two
Wesley needs to brace for impact
yes and the key thing for Wesley is that
once at that pawn marches to E4 that
Wesley does not relinquish the tension
in the center instead he maintains it
for as long as possible
Judith who would you take here
well I would probably rather take it
with white trying from this side from
that side playing Knight E5 if Knight D7
maybe I go Knight G4 I don't mind to end
up Knight on F2 supporting E4
cookie too he's going a different way of
supporting his e-born push and Wesley
plays copycat when in doubt copy the
opponent and all the Rooks stacked up on
the e-file now but maybe he's going to
go now Knight F2 from the other side
so wow C4 C4 good move I like it good
move but now it makes the e-pawn push
maybe slightly more difficult he's going
from a different angle as you say that
uh Fabiano and Wesley okay B6
so tense
that's the way to do it and Armageddon
in muscle wind situations keep the
tension try step forward if you can and
talking of stepping forward Fabi
immediately C5 locking down the queen
side now
yeah because after C5 maybe A4 will be
the next move and keeping the tension on
the queen side and then maybe regrouping
his Rook from E1 to C1 and suddenly
there is a new Target on C6
prediction Game On Point Judith and yeah
big Target actually Boyd is the one in
charge white holds the key on the queen
side black doesn't want to touch
anything because black will be left
stranded with weaknesses it's like a
minority attack here that white is going
for on the queen side yeah but it seems
like Wesley is completely unfazed
because he just simply steps forward to
his work defends the C6 pawn and at the
right time maybe even has active ideas
on the king side and that's like
daydreaming though
yes definitely possible the only problem
here for white for Fabiano is that he
has to Pace it uh he has to avoid
rushing because this Pawn is vulnerable
and wow hi yeah but G5 is just to take
away the Square from the White Knight
are you sure it doesn't want to go G4
eventually
give it some time yeah watch out for the
black king moving maybe a rook sliding
to G8 and then G4 being pushed a bit
later on
now for white I can imagine a great
Square for the Knight on F5
the problem with these types of night
Maneuvers they take four moves together
Knight F1 Knight H1 G3 F5 and then right
there
it goes the other way
that would have been beautiful with the
Knight coming back to F2 H1 G3 and F5
I'm not saying it's a very Speedy night
and I would have the time for it but
just for the imagination maybe someday
it's definitely on a fabi's radar and up
to this point both players playing
quickly the same time difference between
them three minutes to start uh what's
the time deficit for Wesley and still is
three minutes seven Now versus four but
after the night went to B4 now already
G4 makes much more sense for black but
maybe Knight B4 is kind of a provocation
also but of course vastly it's not so
easy to provoke him he just protects his
Queen so I mean this the good news about
that is that at least uh Black's Knight
on F6 can be released from defensive
duties and I like this move from Wesley
just uh Shifting the queen to the e-line
keeping an eye on E3
Pawn here that's the root of all kind of
troubles here for Fabi can he hold that
pawn while going for his own action
Queen D2 just maneuvering now
what do you think will we see Wesley
switch Pace will he uh switch things up
and go for the attack eventually with G4
or is he just going to curl up into a
ball but I wasn't sure this was possible
ah oops A5 yeah Knight T4 okay
he's got a square Black's got a terrible
Pawn structure now with a backward Pawn
Knight A4 Knight D5 Queen moves away
okay it got sharp Rook C5 if you want
before the Black Knight comes in and
locks up that C file final E4 in the
game this is a sacrifice
what are his numbers
oh wow and look at this a double
question mark move and blunder there
from Wesley so he must have missed this
one A5 C4 is not possible anymore he has
to go back and then D5 will be I guess
and uh
hmm and he was banking on this move E3
but the White Queen is simply going to
step away no matter where she goes she
has to keep an eye on this white knight
there we go she retreats to E1 D5 is
going to be a hammer blow next move uh
due to the pin as you mentioned on the C
file we saw that double question mark
move huge blunder and the problem is for
black that after Knight D7 D5 is not
only the C6 Pawn which is under attack
but the E3 is going to be falling off as
well because there is no good place for
The Rook to move away
Black's position is collapsing it's just
like that go cash game it's just
passports just throw your pawns forward
and the opponent is struggling to deal
with him now the gokash is a postpone
guy I mean he has so many passports all
the time
but it just Bobby's learning yeah it
does highlight the cruelness of Chess
though because I think Worsley played a
great game but then he made one terrible
blunder and that's it his position fell
apart
well that's that's how it can turn out
to be unfortunately great spot from
fabidado to play E4 to tempt Wesley into
grabbing a pawn wow
wow peace Sacrifice from Wesley so
deciding that retreating allowing white
Ford was not an option and now the
material count is night for two pawns
black has a strong E3 Pawn but it won't
survive too long
you feel like even moves like D5
well
put the boot in that's a very Fabby type
of move he'll calculate simplify the
equation trade off more pieces trade off
more Pawns a passive player like me
would be inclined to just Retreat hold
the default one and try to round up uh
Black's pass Pawn on E3 I think at this
point several strong moves for white
yeah but still the technique is very
important how you convert an advantage
when you have
I like your idea best actually you know
it's safer and if you know five minutes
there's still some trouble left I know
he goes on my move oh
and that's a good day Knight takes porn
and the problem for black is that they
can't slide over the Rook to C6 because
the Knight will come to E7 and give a
deadly check
yeah proxy 697 is not one to blunder but
how to save this one it doesn't look
terrible Queen C5 right can take on E3
and after F5 the king just moves out to
H1
yeah but maybe not
maybe F1 the white king will hide on
just to make sure everything is
protected it is protected
yeah now running with the B Pawn but it
doesn't look quick enough that black B
Pawn is not going to run too much
further
he's so close now
if he wins this game Fabi then Hikaru
Nakamura must not lose otherwise he will
win the tournament
okay 19c3 this line you're mentioning
Judah on point here but white king
simply steps out of the pin as you
pointed out let's protect everything
curl up into a ball all of white pieces
nicely coordinated now the White Knight
is free to move do you rush with that do
you move the White Queen at the same
time if you move away video or night
then Queen C4 or queen B5 tying you up a
little bit
it's a nasty pin
still a bit annoying White's night now
not ideally placed yeah the same time
you can release the tension with Knight
B2 Queen D2 and queen D3 and then
everything
on Exchange mode
just wondering where the black queen
should pin from yeah this Pawn will get
to B3 but no further
white tonight will blockade
and there we go he does pin I think
you're right Judah just some order
Knight B2 Queen D2 and white still in
control
but the evaluation file is not 100
convinced despite White's extra night
here
do you think if there are any swindling
chances
well there is some idea to play maybe
after B3 move away with the Rook to C6
and try to get into C2
it's always hope as long as the clocks
are ticking Fabby slightly nervous there
but he does develop his Queen Another
White Knight is coming
one on the board
threatened no Rook takes Rick
and a mistake apparently there why could
that be a mistake wow what a move from
her from Wesley so dropping back
threatening Checkmate in one move he
threatens to come into G1 but Red Cross
shows a missed opportunity maybe that
was even stronger there
that was a way to equalize the game
Rick takes Rook still very much a
possibility
it needs to be calculated Rook takes
Rook leads potentially to
simplifications
I think that's the move he wants to play
Fabi
and uh Fabi just under three and a half
minutes whereas Wesley has less than two
minutes on the clock and remember the
players are not getting any increment
until they've passed move 40 and even
then the increment is only one second
yeah we're at move 40 now so they will
be gaining one second per move first
fabi's calculating whether he can take
this Rook without allowing any nasty
checks from behind Queen to G1 check for
example
if he thinks that's safe which it might
well be the white king can start running
then he will go for it
I think he's not going Rook E6 he has to
go back came back to F1
yeah sometimes you've got to go back E3
for example that cannot be played
because that would be a blunder and he
goes Rook E6 he's a calculating machine
Fabi he spent a long time there trying
to work out whether this was viable and
it turns out it is if black of course
because I forgot that we are not
exchanging the Queen's Knight F2
of course Knight F2 and that's all of a
different story then of course Queen
Queen Jack or the queen is very badly
placed on G2 black queen almost trapped
it takes two or three moves to come back
to the D7 maybe is the best black spawns
dropping off
yeah
the pawn on b3's life is Charmed the
question is do you hold on to the H2
Pawn uh My Vibe is yes put it on H3 and
let that Knight be the Supreme Defender
yeah you can tell Wesley's slightly
nervous slightly fidgety here his clock
is ticking down he's at one and a half
minutes now
yeah I think fabi's going to move his
Queen H3 also uh sophisticated but
feels like a finesse too far you can
give some checks you can step forward go
Pawn hunting for white
if I'll be down to two minutes
surely he's going to win this one now as
long as he keeps one point alive look at
that
he keeps two points alive everything
protected I like the fact that he's
making my moves
black queen trying to come out now but
Fabi with a bunch of checks we'll be
able to start grabbing pawns because
black cannot go all the way to F6
defending the E6 spawn because now it's
not been the F2 Knight so Knight E4 will
be on the board this is the big issue
for black so he's going to zigzag over
and he can start maybe even by grabbing
this B3 point I think he's just grabbing
the E6 and after B2 Queen F6 and grabs
the other one but he can actually go
Queen B8
and Bank everything on the B3 Pawn but
then Queen F6 Queen G6 Queen H6 Queen G5
so it's got it right everything is gonna
be collected and it's really accurate
the move order here as you said all
these pawns are going to drop off with
track here we go first the H6 Pawn will
drop with a check next to G5 form will
most likely drop with a check as well
well he has to go King F7 I believe but
uh
good news for white as you have a safety
net here the White Knight can always
come across and stop block this black
b-pawn
should be enough now the extra material
white will have passports of his own to
start pushing
is King being chased away
can't step forward
oh it's a bad news for Wesley on every
level
yeah his time is getting low
I think we might not even fight on too
much longer here Wesley so he knows this
is hopeless especially against her
someone's so accurate someone so precise
like Fabiano but they don't give up so
easily I think he'll give up now
either black will have to trade queens
or give up the B3 Pawn
he's running he's got to run forward but
Fabiano delivering all of the correct
checks
here it comes
uh he wants the G5 Pawn first he wants
everything greedy Fabiano
[Laughter]
efficiently
another black pawn drops with a check
and now the black king being chased in
circles the White Knight is going to
join the action very shortly
first another check what a good
technique
there we go
handshake Fabiana takes the win well
done an important uh one and a half
points for Fabiana caruana and Wesley so
walks away with one point but what an
impressive Armageddon game from Fabi
incredible stuff the way that he set up
that trick and then his technique at the
end was just pristine
yeah that was a very nice way of doing
it but it also means that he understands
the position very well he knew that what
kind of nuances existing in this kind of
position because actually E4 having the
pin on the C file and playing the E5 is
not so original it is part of this type
of positions right so it's important
that you can see on his play Fabiano
knows so well all the ins and outs of
the of the middle game of the positions
what he's playing
yep congratulations to Fabiano shows
he's a man in form he spotted that
tactic that tricks so quickly and Wesley
reacted equally equally quickly but with
a mistake and here we see one of the
remaining games uh still going on or
should we do a quick action replay of
that Victory from Fabiano let's actually
quickly go back there and it was this
moment that we were talking about drew
that here it looks like black is fine
jumping in with Knight to C4 next move
but instead E4 landed and this provoked
a blunder from Wesley so instead he
should be playing the move C5 breaking
out it's all about pushing pawns this
round apparently but Paul takes Pawn was
a mistake as we see double question mark
due to fabi's instant replay A5 and even
after the White Queen was hit just
retreating he simply couldn't keep this
Black Knight now because if it had
stepped back D5 would have been a killer
blow hitting this Rook hitting this pawn
and due to the pin white is winning yes
because you see such a Armageddon time
controller very when it's getting
shorter time control these things count
very much that which player are seeing
instantly some ideas so when E4 was
played by Fabiano instantly understood
that oops there is it's important that
the D5 Pawn is gone so Knight C4 is not
possible in that position
so well this this was the problem for
Wesley that he don't did not realize the
dangers coming
yeah Wesley had to give up a piece and
Fabiano converted very nicely
yeah leaves us with three games
remaining exceptional technique yes
yeah absolutely and uh going to the
bird's eye view
as David mentioned three games remaining
and you wanted to dive straight into one
game David oh I don't know they're all
really exciting though Ivanka maybe
apart from the uh abdic Center of
against Nakamura game that one's still
looking balanced even if there's some
changes there but Ivanka where should we
go the other two games are on fire right
now
oh tricky tricky Drizzy um I'm thinking
maybe we should go to the one that's
more unclear because I feel that good
cash is clearly much better but it's not
that uh certain what's happening between
alireza farouza and Anish giri
okay let's check out what's happening in
this race for first prize I'm not sure
if it's still mathematically possible
now that Fabiano has won his uh
Armageddon game I think these two are
out of the running for first but still a
lot to play for and
yeah for Asia he's been showing with
Really Brave courageous play that he
wants to win in the classical portion
he's just played the move G5 we
mentioned he sacrificed The Exchange a
bit earlier Judith and he's going for
the black king if the Black Knight moves
then White's Queen might be able to
swoop in in answer to your question one
of them might be mathematically possible
to catch him up but that's that's highly
dependent on Hikaru
beating Fabiano
tomorrow so that will be Anish Guri
who's slightly ahead of feruja now in
the standings
okay so for Anish a win is imperative if
he wants any chances of Glory in the
tournament but right now how does he
deal with this hit on his Knight I'm
looking at the position and I'm trying
to find my bearings but it's not so easy
it looks like so much tension here but I
don't see any tactics against the white
king yet
well I don't know if there is any
quantity chance like playing Rook A6
so just in case force divide Queen
moving away because indeed if I go I
move away with the knight from F6 then
Queen E8 and Rook D7 and these move Look
frightening at first though maybe it's
not the end of the world so let's see
what happens of Knight G4 yeah Knight G4
quite likely here let's jump in and show
this uh Knight G4
maybe one of the most likely moves or at
least one of the most natural moves for
initial
and I guess that would be met by a queen
check maybe even a rook check that one
comes in from behind track with the
queen and after King H7 uh maybe there's
97 in that position B8 and Rook d8 I
don't know it's so chaotic here white
going for the attack but let's take a
pause from this chaos let's certainly
take a pause because it is our pleasure
to welcome into the studio Fabiana
Carano who just defeated Wesley so in
the Armageddon congratulations that
looked like a very impressive game yeah
it went rather rather smoothly although
I think it was very complicated but he
he blundered when he took on e4
but I was happy to play the Armageddon I
I mean I thought it was a good outcome
if I'd say both I and Hikaru draw today
and uh darmegen was pretty low pressure
as I mean as long as Hikaru doesn't win
then then it's a whole other story but
if he draws then the Armageddon actually
doesn't really make a difference for
tomorrow I mean I have to not lose and
he has to to win
and
so you had a rest day you came off that
rest day losing to gagash I mean how are
you feeling
oh I didn't really didn't care so much
I I mean in the Armageddon anything can
happen and I actually played a
relatively decent game I thought uh I
actually think I was hurt by not having
much experience like all these guys had
played a lot of Armageddon and I only
played one and I didn't realize that you
basically can't play with one like I
can't physically move the pieces with
one second increment I didn't expect
that so I wasn't worried getting low on
time
and then once I got low in time I'm like
I'm actually just flagging I I can't
physically make the moves and especially
because he had these like short King
moves and I had the long Queen moves
that it was much more difficult to make
long Queen moves uh and yeah so I
thought okay it happens it was kind of
an accident uh not really like fully
chess related let's say
um and it didn't really impact the
tournament so much so I wasn't too upset
okay
and uh so facing Wesley your intention
was just to play solid chess in the
classical and then Armageddon time where
were you surprised that he switched it
up to a Queen's Gambit declined I was
pleasantly surprised although I had
something crazy in mind in the nimso
which I I won't reveal maybe some
someday I'll play it it was a pretty
ridiculous idea and I didn't get a
chance to play it but it's probably good
because it probably wouldn't have worked
out
I'm curious now Fabi but I won't push
you too much on the nimsy I'll tell I'll
tell you after the broadcast is over
okay deal I'll sign an NDA don't worry
and uh you mentioned the Armageddon
maybe you can take us through some of
the critical moments here yeah I think
there was one very critical moment
um basically probably his decisive
mistake but let's say when he played 94
that was like the first
um I guess critical move because it's
it's a pretty standard position and okay
he went for a standard idea 94 which
isn't of course necessary but I can also
play for for sure many other moves like
A5 for example
um I took took rookie one
and then he went for Bishop five it
surprised me a bit because he's allowing
me to change the structure
but
I wasn't sure if the structural change
is good but anyway I thought it's more
Dynamic so I went for this F3
uh and at least now I have yeah the
extra Pawn break with C4
which um it felt like my play Maybe is a
bit more straightforward
but still black is of course very very
solid and then I was happy when he
played B6 and I got the C5 because it
felt like maybe C6 becomes a bit of a
weakness
like I thought he didn't really have to
play B6 he yeah now C6 is a bit weaker
like if I play C5 with the pawn on B7 I
don't really have a path forward on the
queen side so now I have a ways to
attack C6
and then I thought it's a bit more
pleasant for me
uh although it's it's still I guess
completely equal and then he he
blundered but at a moment when I was
starting to get very interesting
uh yeah G5
oh you're impressed by G5 I didn't
expect it uh and but anyways maybe it's
good and uh
after Knight takes B6
and I played E4 and he took on e4 very
quickly I think it was a bit uh
basically just the when you're low on
time sometimes you make these impulse
decisions and that's this was one of
them of course if you play Knight C4
Queen C3 it's just a very complicated
very complicated position I
um I was happy to get E4 in at least
I see like maybe Knight C4 is not a good
move but I thought it's the most natural
move apparently C5 is just chaos but
level okay yeah I didn't I didn't see C5
at all I thought either Knight C4 or D
for the the moves and D4 is just A5 I
don't see a way to survive anymore
because D5 comes it's just uh
his position is in Ruins
how much uh was this Instinct and how
much was calculation you played E4 quite
quickly
well I don't know if I have anything
else I mean I don't deny on C4 is going
to attack E3 and I have no way to get
rid of it so E4 I mean it was connected
with cb6 because I thought if I don't
take on B6 I probably can't really play
for an advantage
and this way at least I get E4 and then
Knight C4 Queen C3 I thought my Rook
moves and maybe I'll Attack the D5 pawn
and then he'll have to deal at least
with some difficult decisions
D4 was like very obviously bad so I
didn't really spend much time on it
and uh talking about the
so here it was relatively
straightforward yeah I think so I think
he actually chose a good practical
decision because Knight D7 D5 he'll
he'll probably lose much more than just
a piece because he loses C6 and E3 and
maybe A7 and
maybe also a rook so
it doesn't sound too appealing it's
usually not great so I thought at least
he sacks a piece and he
he tries to capture as many pawns as he
can he actually captured quite a few but
I always had uh
I mean he blundered when he played Queen
g3 at the end Queen H2 he still keeps
the fight alive at least practically
with um
with low time but Queen G3 he he just he
allowed me to take his E6 Pawn as well
because we're clear on H2 with his King
can go to F6 and there's no night Forks
and I thought for example here I can
play Queen to E3 and then Queen B8 Queen
E6 okay it's it's winning for sure but
like I I still have to to work for it
um
and yeah maybe Queen E3 wasn't the most
accurate yeah
and uh by the way we do have news on
Hikaru he's just drawn his game against
naughty bag yeah that's good news but
not too surprising considering the
position
yeah but what about the other games
they're like completely wild I mean yeah
so uh let's uh bring up the bird's eye
view and uh get your hot take on them
so the game that we were
very well we're very curious about both
these games
but uh which one catches your fancy
okay I guess
Ariana's down in exchange and the C7
Pawn is pretty strong so like I guess
Ali Reza's game is much more up in the
air than that one that one I think
kukash will win and he's actually having
a really really really good tournament
really impressive tournament
what alirez's game is very interesting
let's dive in and have a look and it
feels like a critical moment both sides
have just over the 10 minutes left on
their clock instincts wise Fabi who do
you pick and why what instant can you
have in this position okay why it's done
in exchange and uh
where does the Knight go to H
seven rook d8 and Bishop C5 right so
um
where is the night going
and is there Queen takes E4 also there's
a question
because Queen A7 there's some potential
tactics I don't know
no yeah actually Queen E4 is very
critical no Queen E4 and let's say for
argument's sake I take on A7 I realized
that F5 is hanging so this is just a hot
as bad
so Queen takes E4 what does white play
here
too complicated for this late in the
tournament well probably exchange and
Rook d8 Jack
and what's the follow-up I don't know
King G2
yeah I was thinking about Black's pieces
are pretty miserable but it is a lot of
material
also the question is what about Rook D7
after King H7
uh in that case do you want the King on
jira you want it on H7 right I want it
on H7
they can Bishop D3 yeah
and uh
yeah maybe G6 take Rook B3 is Josh but
hard to say right
on Knight H6 or or do we have just
Knight moves and then Knight D6 is made
by E4 so maybe Knight C3 for example
there's a reasonable move
and can't uh yeah Knight D6 E4
1994 but Rook I rookie seven Knight of
six six yeah so Knight E4 C4 let's let's
wow and Bishop C2 Rook B2 is probably
crushing yeah geometry everywhere
all forced of course all gonna happen
G5 first
and maybe still Queen E4 is in there
yeah I think Oddish calculates very
precisely so he'll I don't think uh that
he'll mess this one up
but since they're both they're both
getting low on time I mean anything
could happen
uh so Fabi what will your uh kind of
approach be tomorrow in this kind of uh
playoff almost against the Hikaru yeah I
have to draw and it's uh it's a pretty
clear
it's like a classic right he has to win
uh the onus is on him and it's usually
not easy but I mean to win on demand
especially these days
especially against you
I think like there's there's definitely
a few guys who I would trust more than
myself like let's say Wesley that's
that's someone I trust if Wesley never
loses I I lose but Wesley never loses
but I also win a few more games I don't
know if that will help me tomorrow
and in terms of uh having a good night's
sleep how do you handle these kind of
situations when everything is so tense
I I've been sleeping well here and
um actually it's I've been feeling
pretty good physically here like in in
Bucharest I was feeling really miserable
physically and here I feel much much
better
um so sleeping hasn't been a problem
it also helps that the games are light
so we can wake up late in the morning
usually I've been waking up like 9 9 30
which is pretty late for me and
um yeah I've been able to get like eight
hours of sleep which is much more than I
usually get I usually I'm I'm a bit over
six let's say during tournaments but
eight hours is uh is very good for me so
I I've been feeling rested hopefully
that doesn't you know the the the time
when I struggle to sleep is usually when
I've messed up it's not like before big
games but it's when I've done something
unforgivable and that I can't sometimes
can't get to sleep are you really
sleeping many times during the
tournament six hours only well like six
and a half very often you know it's it's
pretty common probably you're the player
who sleeps the less
maybe maybe I don't know I don't know
about otherwise I'm sleeping only this
much you're preparing crazy no no no I I
don't
um I'm just used to it like I I usually
get up pretty early when I'm not doing
tournaments but I usually get up pretty
early and I usually sleep like maximum
seven hours
um that's just I don't know normally how
much I sleep
must be the fresh Norwegian air I was
actually thinking that I was I was
because the it is very clean air here
there's like very very little pollution
so maybe that contributes to
she moved to Norway Fabi I recommend
highly recommend it what did you get up
to on the free day uh not much I was
actually preparing quite a bit
um quite a lot for the game I know the
opening Choice didn't show it but a lot
remains you know let's say under the
surface
and uh do you have a routine to get
ready for the games
nothing nothing really too special I
mean I prepare before and I stopped
preparing a bit before the game so I'm
not like staring at a computer the
entire day
uh but besides that like we go for a
walk go out get some food usually
um
nothing too exciting
and meanwhile it looks like we predicted
everything uh Fabi and Judith on the
game between anarisa and Anish
heading straight down that line maybe a
fourth draw incoming how is it a four
straw though after let's say Knight C3
everything up to that point is forced
right yeah that line you mentioned after
E4 maybe white can just play Bishop
takes E4 oh yeah Knight takes E4 Knight
B7 yeah yeah I'm assuming that's a draw
still some life left
a bit to play for maybe we show this on
the board what we're expecting here
um you guys mentioned Rook B7
and now after a trade of Rooks Bishop D3
nice uh kind of pattern here wipe the
exchange down but nowhere to get out of
this and
yeah at least the line you mentioned
after E4 Knight takes E4 didn't seem to
be working out so
uh the only thing I saw in that whole
line that you guys were going through
was that Bishop takes E4 well the
computer doesn't like Knight C3 so we
did something wrong okay
in this position like instead of not C3
is there
what kind of Knight takes F2 I don't
know
ah Knight takes F2 interesting grab
pawns and uh hope for the best
yeah still a bit of life left in the
same game we'll see if we're headed in
that direction Ivanka yeah we certainly
will and uh while you're here Fabi we
actually got an interview with Hikaru
about his chances and he actually
mentions you so it would be interesting
to have your thoughts on this all right
how is it to focus on Armageddon game
now when your mind is probably racing
towards tomorrow already
yeah I mean the thing is at the end of
the game I was in a similar situation to
my game against
um
who was it I made the draw Ali Raza
actually and it was the same thing where
I was trying to think my mind I mean if
I win the game I think I'm down by half
point so I don't think it makes a big
difference for tomorrow and so I'm just
like no reason not to take the draw and
just just um just play it out but yeah I
think
pretty much regardless of this arm again
I think I have to win tomorrow to win
the tournament I actually think it's
it's more or less first or second
guaranteed so yeah we'll see I mean this
army gun doesn't matter we'll see how
tomorrow goes
is there still a rivalry between you and
Fabiano
I mean rivalry I think is too strong
where I think we all know each other too
well at this point we've played too many
games so um I mean competitors I think
it's the way of putting it I wouldn't
say that I think of us as Rivals I'll
let you focus on Armageddon and have a
chat after thank you sure thanks
so he says you're not Rivals just simply
competitors
what's what's the difference I don't
know
apples and pears
um
yeah and uh Fabiano it's not just
tournament Victory on the line also the
world rankings you'll be number two as
long as you avoid defeat tomorrow is
that something on your mind or less
relevant Ali Raza could win right
true I forgot about that I I don't I
don't care about that too much I mean
the tournament is the important thing
for me I whether Ali Reza wins uh I mean
if I if I lose tomorrow I'll be
extremely
extremely upset and it won't be because
of the rating but because uh because I
missed out on a tournament win but
the the ratings are not something I'm
looking at too closely at the moment
and uh so um
I wanted to ask you about uh what were
your plans after this tournament
well
so I actually have to to make a
chessable course and I it's like nine
months now that I've had to to finish it
I think it's it's only like nine months
they're probably uh thinking that I'll
never finish at this point but I'm close
and after this I probably have to get on
that a little bit and then feel the
title
uh it's gonna be a lifetime repertoire
um I don't know if I should say the
opening although it's
it's probably not like a huge secret but
tell me later Fabiano I was going to ask
whether you're using your chestival
course in this tournament I played a
different opening every every game
pretty much so it would be a very
extensive accessible course if I was
covering all openings yeah no I I
haven't been um been playing it in this
tournament
oh interesting you know I was surprised
when I saw and heard giri's repair to
her and also Wesley so and some others
are giving out the secrets of their
aperture and I'm pretty sure that they
keep some of them it's it's not that
they tell everything but still for
amateurs I believe that it's a huge
thing just to see them
uh go through on the lines explaining
the middle games and still after all
they talk about their own reporter right
for me it was something very amazing
that it happens isn't it strange for you
that on the top level players are
sharing at least some part of their
repaired horse
I think it's all it's kind of a sign of
the times also that there's so much
uh so many options
so it's not like I give away my analysis
and I feel like I I don't have anything
to play anymore I still feel like you
can you can share a lot and then there's
still a lot to to be able to play
um and like with mine I'm just I'm not
hiding anything actually it's it's stuff
that I've just analyzed from scratch
pretty much
um and I I it's stuff that I would play
also uh
so
it's an opening which I I have played
and I I will play and I what I recommend
I'm I'm also willing to play myself so
so I actually by making the course
you're developing your own strategies
for the upcoming tournaments I've I've
already used some of it
so it feels like less like a course down
more like just stuff I'm using and I
used
um I used it in my last two tournaments
and I made two draws with it so that was
pretty successful thanks
detectives out there will figure out
what everything it is now yeah they will
be searching your Anonymous accounts on
chess.com
um anyway thank you very much Fabi for
joining us and I'd like to wish you good
luck in tomorrow's game and uh once
again congratulations on beating um
Wesley in the Armageddon game thank you
thank you
and uh it was great to have a Favi in
the studio giving us his inside thoughts
and sharing with us his analysis of uh
not only his game but other games as
well and there we see noribe naude back
getting ready to play off against Hikaru
Nakamura now
no day back has a 10 minutes on the
clock Hikaru will have seven minutes on
the clock but nerdy back will have that
must win situation in his mind
I mean how difficult is it to play
Hikaru Nakamura knowing he's so fast and
at the same time you've got to beat him
it is of course very difficult to place
Nakamura as he's also in a good form
basically at the same time when you're
young the tournament is not going well
and okay it was a draw not very
interesting game in the classical game
you're still there okay this is my time
I'm going to be winning and and he wants
to pose real trouble to Nakamura I
believe and this is how it should be
even such young talents around and we
know that uh no de Becky's just been an
incredible form in Rapid and Blitz chess
in the last few months he won the chess
kid cup he won the blitz tournament
before this event so he's confident
there I think uh just the fact that he
struggles slightly with the classical in
the last few days it won't be too big of
an issue of course facing hikara is the
big issue but he's got to take his
chances and it's maybe good for uh Abdul
sator of here that's for Nakamura the
result doesn't matter too much he's
still in the same situation tomorrow a
draw or a loss oh sorry a winner or loss
same thing at the same time of course
Nakamura also a player who is extremely
competitive so obviously he would not
like to lose this game or that if things
go wrong it will not affect him too much
for tomorrow but still just in case he
wants to win
and in the meantime we can see that
kukash did Notch up an important three
points in the standings by defeating
Aryan Atari so only one classical game
remaining between alireza and Anish
oh so go cash still in the running if
the results work his way or maybe not
actually I've got to say whether Google
is in the running or not it was a
masterpiece that game just beautiful
play from start to finish so I
definitely recommend going and playing
through that one in a bit more detail uh
yeah especially if you want to learn
about passports yeah it was very
originally played by gokash playing H4
then later on put his Knight on C6 with
B4 B5 protecting it I mean you could
think that there is no way that you're
going to be seeing postpones in that
game and suddenly somehow it was going
through like water anywhere
for me it was the visual impact of
having all those Pawns in the middle of
the board and just knowing that someone
was gonna give
um yeah well we are going to be treated
in a few minutes to a third Armageddon
game between no dear back and Hikaru
or if you were notibex coach
what advice would you give him like tell
him what opening strategy would you go
for go for the long game go shop
well I think he has to go for something
else than what he did in this game if
Nakamura plays the same system and
concentrate think nothing else but the
game and be their presence and you
detect some nervousness from the
teenager yes I do we can see that with
him fidgeting with his fingers
yeah he's trying to get focused that's
how abdisotaref has written to the top
of wheelchair so quickly he's got
extreme focus when he's in the flow in
the zone but Meanwhile we're off it's a
King's Pawn opening Nakamura only needs
a draw so he's happy to repeat the
Berlin defense and straight down the
same opening variation Judith are you
surprised by this I'm extremely
surprised by this that to go into this
line again it was not so fantastic was
it it was not so fantastic but it's
Nakamura who is the first to deviate
choosing a slightly different variation
ultimately however ending up in a
similar Pawn structure so the only
difference between this game and the
earlier game was the fact that the Black
Knights aren't dancing around so much
and the fact that there's an extra set
of minor pieces on the board still at
the Berlin is Rock Solid and out of
everyone at the top of World Chess I
think Hikaru is the one who's had this
position this variation the most he
knows everything there is to know
nodabek needs some things special to
imbalance this game well I'm curious
what will be A4 on the board it seems
like now the wreck really likes to play
on the queen side with the pawns and
interestingly enough A5 stop the white
Pawn it's also you can see that Nakamura
doesn't like it when there is these push
pawns and the space is taken away from
him yeah top level these days it's all
about pushing rook's pawns if one side
pushes the other side normally blocks
and talking of block this is pretty much
completely symmetrical the pawn
structure the only difference being that
White's Rook sits on the only open file
is G4 possible now no not G7 I thought
there is a trap
so close the Black Knight actually does
retreat back to G7 anyway only one safe
square but good enough yeah next move
Nakamura is getting ready to bring his
one of his pieces out to F5 so that has
been prevented by Knight G3 or has it
but it's interesting because usually
these kind of positions is with one pair
of knights are exchanged already and
right now it's a question whether white
is allowing this or he moves away
and he allows that trade and David
didn't you have a similar game when you
played against Alpha zero or something
at least a similar Pawn structure yeah
almost identical Pawn structure I've had
this many times myself white black but
normally as Judith mentions there's one
set of minor pieces off the board that
normally favors black just because here
we see white is slightly ahead of
development that's why Nakamura is
spending time now uh going for peace
trades because if you're slightly
cramped if you're under pressure
alleviating that pressure with the
trades does tend to help and you can see
that the Nakamura is not exchanging the
knights on G3 but he wants to eliminate
the important Knight on F3 because if
let's say there is Knight H4 Queen H4
the Knight on G3 stands much worse the
key idea in this position to centralize
the Knight to E5 but right now it seems
for me that 95 would be getting in
trouble after F6
yeah suddenly if white is forced to
trade off these Knights Black's Queen
comes out black has no issues whatsoever
space troubles all sorted black is the
one active uh so really nice move there
from Nakamura it just feels like Abdu
satoroff has gone into hikaru's comfort
zone here uh he's kind of walked into
the cave walked into the bear trap and
that trade has happened I think Knight
H4 was a very important and very good
move yeah that was an important one not
an obvious one but it cost Hikaru
basically no time at all because he's
such an expert in this Pawn structure
and at some point nodabek needs to try
something whether that's pushing a pawn
at some point with C4 just to try and
break the structure change things up
whether that's trying some tactics later
on who knows but it looks balanced to me
I like very much your C4 idea to be
honest but at the moment I believe that
the D4 Pawn is under attack and black
would be capturing it so white is
actually started to go back with the
Knight to F1
yeah he wants to kick away the black
queen and before she gets kicked away a
retreating move
so arguing that the White Knight is less
well placed the black queen is solid
this is a surprise for my queen d8 why
was it so fast Hikaru to go to C7 and to
relieve the Bishop from C8 to play
Bishop F5 I guess that's the idea he
wants to defend this B Pawn uh so his
Bishop can develop and bring it out to
F5 but yeah very strange it feels like
her car is just trying to play bullet
chess he's only spent less than a minute
we're already at moved 20.
just impressive speed he's actually
closed the time uh kind of the time
deficit already only 30 seconds
difference now between them
yeah sent his pieces oh making their way
towards the king side you can see that
night it's getting ready to put itself
on G5 and maybe there might even be some
sacrifices in the air or as F4 as David
has highlighted Bishop coming out to
attack The Rook no big deal Brooke moves
away
suddenly the White Queen wants to be on
the other side of the board
okay stepping forward upon just taking
away this key Square on F4 from Black's
pieces
hikara still needs to develop the queen
side of this bishop this Rook we can
just develop his light squared Bishop
one square because the pawn on B7 cannot
be grabbed because you simply chasing
chase the queen away
yeah the White Queen will get eternally
chased there maybe even trapped and of
course the draw is enough for Hikaru so
that pawn is Untouchable white should be
playing Knight H2 Knight G4
or
or Knight F3 Knight E5 yeah you called
it Judith just before Abby satorva
played it the White Knight is coming
back to the center
it wants to land on this beautiful
Square on E5 where it will cost black
the bishop pair
yeah still a bit tense I think the last
few moves up to satora's done really
well just creating some chances at all
this is what I I had the feeling also
that in the last few moves it seems like
white recovered from badly placed Knight
for example
right but uh yeah white might have
recovered from those bad pieces but he
is in a must-win situation and the pawn
structure is looking very level and the
more minor pieces that gets traded off
the easier it is for Hikaru to get that
unnecessary draw I was surprised that
it's not Knight G4 what was played but
probably after King G7 Knight D4 threat
what was bothering him
yeah he's so good at just staying solid
not doing too much just covering squares
ready to defend and okay the White
Knight jumps in the key question is does
black tolerate this night or does it
does he kick away this piece immediately
maybe at the cost overnight for Bishop
trade steps back
and in time there is no big difference
because Nakamura plays so fast and
another back has only half a minute
extra compared to Nakamura
psychologically that must be so
unsettling for Abdul Torah but he's
playing quickly himself he drops back
with his Queen getting ready to bring
her over to some dark squares on the
king side so potentially getting ready
to soften up the king side with H4 H5
but I believe F6 will happen on the
board but of course that's the
provocation what not the another back is
doing no C5
I'm worried on Black's position Bishop
E5 giving this such a weak spot making
such a weakness yeah we saw it only
briefly but C5 was given a question mark
by the engine maybe a mistake maybe just
worsening the black position because
suddenly the black Bishop is completely
trapped the black Rook on air cannot get
out but how is that possible it was
developing to D7 and then few moves
later it's back on
in the way right now
next one or two moves to develop and
your queen has uh has moved to D2 which
means that Knight G4 is now a
possibility as well as this H5 idea oh
it's looking unpleasant for Hikari just
the last four or five moves ever since
that Bishop Retreat it's all turned
against him Abdul soturf has swung this
game in his favor he's dominant on the
dart squares loving these white Pawn
chains on dark squares now and black is
just too passive he needs to break out
but how to do that
yes because it's not only the C8 Bishop
but the A8 Rook is also stuck there
yeah this cannot get out the bishop
cannot get out okay he steps back with
the Black Knight well probably that was
the only move or somehow trying to get
out he covers his diagonal with his
Bishop but it was given a question mark
this knight move and that's because
white has stepped forward H5 H6 is
coming the black king is already being
trapped and mating that is being weaved
around it
already it feels so scary it certainly
does and I'm not a big fan of Hikaru
closing the tension in the center
because this simply gives white a
completely free hand on the king side
the White Queen can come in
do you use this Square F4 do you use G5
it feels like one of these Queen moves
must be strong
I think F4 I was thinking
yeah this is the same reason I want to
go Queen F4 because after Queen D6
Knight G6 yes that's what I wanted as
well but okay but maybe it doesn't work
because check on E1 and queen G6 oh
there's some tactics well Queen F4
this is the launch pad for him the White
Queen needs two moves to sneak in and
Checkmate on the G7 Square kanhikaru
block this off and delay it when the six
oh there must be tactics in the air the
black queen can cover the white Queen's
infiltration Square on F6 but well
actually I'm still Queen these six maybe
Knight C4 is possible
tactics and take Stakes
the White Knight will jump out the way
with the discovery will we see this
you're thinking Knight takes Pawn there
uh Judith looks very tempting because I
want to tie at the end with rookie ate
all the pieces yeah but there's also no
threat for black there's no good
developing move so you can just take the
liberty of moving your king up to F6
might be a move
right but already then you want to take
on Jesus yes
the other question is between D6 or
queen B6
oh
and uh well Hikaru Nakamura under two
and a half minutes on the clock I think
Queen B6 would be safer in the ground
scheme of things but he called then
Knight C4 Knight C4 really works
position yes
okay F5
oh he's he's a one of the best defenders
on the planet wow and uh okay we've
moved to another game just briefly
because there's seconds left on the
clock between ferrugia and giri as well
this game could be decided any second
we'll come back to the Armageddon in a
moment where it's really critical Hikaru
has blocked he's pushing the pawn to F5
and
um this one it's literally 25 seconds
against 30 seconds between uh these two
players it's been a crazy game it's
level material do we think it's going to
be a draw well it can be a draw if white
goes uh Knight E5 for example right
there is a very good chance but maybe E4
and white wants to win E5 E6
and that's nicely covered by the black
Bishop covering the E5 Square now oh it
feels like a so so promising here so
appealing for ferrisa but there's no
knockout blue black is everything
covered and Bishop D6 in the next move
oh maybe he wants to go rook and Bishop
wow we might see an end game White
having a rook and Bishop against a rook
in two pawns which should be a draw but
let's move yeah
because things are happening in both
games it's gonna end soon
yeah because Annie should be a draw
objectively it's a draw so if we can
move back to another back oh that's over
wow just missed a killer Blow from NoDa
back
wow
yeah meanwhile this game should be a
draw but it's going to go on for a long
long time between ferrugia and Gary now
as far Asia tries to grind away with
this extra Bishop let's go back to the
other game
we'll show an action replay of the drama
of what happened it just finished
nakamura's just resigned
well shall we do an action replay of
those last few moves
yes
thereafter F5 something really went
wrong but already then it was uh I think
there was no way that Nakamura could
have been saving the game it was so
difficult for him simply the last few
moves when we left already it was so
dangerous the pawn on H6 having the
potential mate eventually on G7 the
black squares
and here he went F5 right yeah and this
is where there was the stunning blow of
Knight takes Pawn
Knight takes C4 we see double
exclamation mark unexpected looks
impossible because this Knight is
hanging but this trick relies on two
factors uh if the Knight is captured
then we see I think white just takes
this point with a nasty check and the
problem is if you take this bishop Rook
takes rook and this king is getting
checkmated still the same idea of the
White Queen sneaking in uh instead after
Knight takes Pawn we saw a queen trade
but this didn't help until another black
Rook is hanging and after uh Knight to
E6 okay surprising end there I thought
Rook takes Rook would at least happen
but this would have been a beautiful
finish as well Bishop takes Pawn with a
check forcing the king in the corner and
rookie eight next you pin and you win
black is utterly paralyzed immobilized
here and game over instead Nakamura
tried to defend with Knight E6 but after
the Knight came to B6 and landed he just
played one more move and resigned in
disgust everything is winning here for
white you can take this Pawn for example
two extra pawns and a dominant position
it is and this Victory from nederbeck
means that uh Hikaru has to beat Fabiana
caruana tomorrow in their classical
encounter for him to win Norway chess
wow what a game and uh one classical
game remaining and it's been such an
intense battle between alireza farooja
and Anish giri and other players are
just making their moves with seconds
left on the clock but here it seems to
be
a draw it's a classical game but it's
completely on Armageddon uh feeling
already but the case is that if it's a
draw we still have a treat and they're
going to be playing an Armageddon
afterwards
but black is not giving up the pawns not
at all Anish does not want to play Only
The Rook versus the rook and Bishop
because then he has to show all the
technique which most likely he could but
he doesn't want to get there just
keeping both of his Pawns
and moving the king so white king is
completely under uh
well it just cannot move blockading the
C3 but it cannot go out
where it seems that I have doubts that
white can kick out the C5 Rook which is
defending both of the pawn C3 and G5
yeah and when there are less than seven
pieces on the board chess has more or
less been solved and you can see what
the computer thinks of these positions
by putting them on the chess.com table
base and it's telling me right now that
more or less everything draws
yep everything draws even without the
black pawns everything draws but uh
Judith do you think we'll get that far
first question second question Anish
will he hold rook and Bishop versus Rook
if it gets to that point first of all we
will not get to there I believe so we
will not see that whether he could be
holding it but I'm pretty sure that he
was studying well enough that even with
very short time he could be managed to
hold the drill without too many
difficulties
yep and the problem is simply no way to
move the king you need to somehow
replace the white king to blockade this
C Pawn uh maybe blockade it with your
Bishop then bring the King around but
this is the perfect defensive setup with
black you mentioned this Rook holding
both the pawns also caging the white
king rookie five is a final move now but
of course Anish will play King after
King E3 King G3 King F2 like Fabiano
said quick King they're the quickest
and the easiest as well it says
farrugia while he's built up some time
on the clock but it's only 43 seconds
it's not a lot yeah he wanted to use his
Bishop to plant it on C4 block the
connection between the black rook and
the C1 but the problem is then his Rook
starts getting harassed from the black
king
still no way through
easy moves for Gary he's building time
on the clock two and a half minutes
almost now for Gary
he was down at 20 seconds not long ago
but his moves are simple
yeah I don't think we'll get there
either I think armageddon's almost
guaranteed At This Point Judith I just
don't see exactly probably after King F2
he wants to go King D3 and somehow bring
the king already but I don't think it
will uh yeah he has an idea of Bishop B3
and Bishop C4
pick up the C3 Pawn
yeah he's making a good job on that
yeah for the first time in a while he
has a plan
good job from faruga but Step One is
winning the black C Pawn step two's
winning the black Jeep one step three is
winning that end game it's not gonna be
easy but that's not the point the point
is somehow to win great success to win
the C3 Pawn then great success and other
30 moves within the G5 pawn and then the
party starts where he can
squeeze a little bit on each that's the
main point for
alireza yeah and of course he's right
I've had this exact same game myself as
well actually a rook and Bishop versus
rook and C and G pawns against a
stronger and master never off and it
took me 50 moves to win the first one
about 20 moves to win the second pawn
and only five moves to win the rook and
Bishop versus Rook he immediately
collapsed so you're right dude it does
happen it's possible but this is Anish
giri I'm expecting
expecting something slightly more
tenacious here that was a nice story
David or maybe it was closer to 10 moves
to win the rookie Bishop Mrs Rook but he
did fall apart so
um yeah Gary now needs something made
the great job taking that c Pawn
he needs to get the Jeep on rolling but
it's covered at the moment well he can
step forward with his King to F3
and uh if King takes Pawn then you can
go G4 because also black does have the
resolve resource of actually giving The
Rook up for the bishop and pinning all
his hopes on the G Pawn there you go
okay one is gone step one
big moral victory for alireza but is it
enough for victory in the game King back
he's trying to set a mating net up
around the black king
to push that point or not to push the
pawn
I think let's push the pawn
yeah now Black's fish uh black skin is
going to be checked by the white Bishop
not sure which angle you want to check
from he steps back
King G2
King F2 forcing The Rook to F4 first and
then maybe he's going to be playing King
G1
creating a square for his G Pawn to push
to he's getting ever closer to yeah to
that draw it might cost why his Bishop
that g Pawn
to do now like he's working hard to keep
the Jeep on and that he does not have to
show his technique in this simple
uh Rook Bishop against rook and game
because there are so many people losing
it but also many could hold it I could
also hold it once I was very proud of
that do you also want it as well yeah
Bishop yeah I think to get to qualify
you know again Dominguez yeah I was
watching that and it was game eight but
the problem here is that black can
absolutely not lose that G3 Pawn I mean
if he does lose it I mean his king would
be on the bottom row and it would be a
big disaster so as David mentioned it
probably would take maybe five five
moves for alireza to win that but
actually if you know the technique even
when it looks already pretty bad isn't
it there are some drawing options I lost
it quite a few times when I was a
teenager I missed in GM Norm because of
this that I I lost one of those but when
I learned it then it was very clear that
what are the techniques that on
different stages you have the different
techniques how
not to lose it
yep there's various defenses trekking
from afar the second ranked defense yeah
many other names of defenses that I'm
not sure about but uh yeah either way if
you know it you know it but it's not
easy
even if you know it it's not easy so
okay wow did you see that power move
from Gary he reached over the other side
picked up a queen as if his Pawn might
land wow G2 on the board it's close
but surely it won't be allowed to make
it that far
and 17 seconds for Ally Ruiz alireza
Rook comes to shorten the G2 Pawn of
course Gary will hold on to that one for
dear life
took a nervous look at the clock there
shaking his head he knows that that
black pawn is about to land a touchdown
and it will cost white his Bishop
the black King's simply going to move
out the way King G2 King F1 or King H2
big question both are probably
sufficient here black is threatening to
make a new Queen even that would be a
draw Rook versus Bishop is a draw oh
we're gonna see a draw and there is the
handshake
oh how was an epic battle between the
two and the players are giving us a
smile but in 20 minutes they will be off
to play an Armageddon game
what it was a very tough game very
interesting game what was going on what
the middle game we had ups and downs
sacrifices
positional sacrifice but everything
ended up in tactics simplification
and then firoza was testing Anish
whether is he going to be going wrong
and getting
a rogue Bishop versus Rook but there are
some things exciting things which they
share with each other and after all that
excitement I think it's the perfect time
for us to take a breather catch our
breaths refill on our coffee cups and we
will see you all in a few minutes
oh
[Music]
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just clock app right here almost
there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can play keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lapse yeah okay
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get somebody okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
I do like positional styled games I may
try to keep it positional but I I I can
also uh change gears and I think that's
very important in terms of uh
you know anyone trying to develop their
chess game
um if you do find you know style of play
that you enjoy that's good but you could
also try to sharpen it by implementing
you know on another form of
uh into your bag as we would call it
right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to studying geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best from Carlson's fiercest online
rival today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps nodu Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023. Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long-time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and chakriya mamat
yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field
who will come out on top will Carlson
run the table yet again or will someone
else usurp the throne this is Norway
chess
hello and welcome back and after that
shot pause it's time to reignite that
chest fire because well a few minutes
ago we were treated to a lot of
entertainment on the chessboard we saw
Ali Reza and Anish giri just draw it out
in a very spectacular in-game scramble
at some point and then of course we had
Hikaru losing in the Armageddon to no
day back abdisator of wow
yeah that was happening very fast what
happened with another another book
against Hikaru it was a very peaceful
opening that's how that has started out
but then after having a great position
for Nakamura he was just playing very
fast the beginning and everything went
perfectly and then somehow something
went wrong after the exchange of the
nights and the queen moving back and
then it was just collapse yeah and uh
David can you take us through what
happened in the Anish game yeah we saw
that Anish eventually did draw that
difficult end game he was down rook and
Bishop for rook and two pawns which he
held very comfortably but uh it was a
case of missed opportunities for alireza
for Asia and it started around here we
jumped in a bit later on when things
were fizzling out pieces were coming off
the board so the knights got traded and
actually here there was a question mark
attached to Black's last move King G6
was not entirely accurate and maybe a
small missed opportunity for ferrugia
with a bit more time on his clock he was
down to seconds at this point he would
have surely have played the move King to
F4 when actually black is is in some
trouble this king is about to get hit
with a nasty check on this diagonal
black pieces cannot check the white king
the white king is super safe and the
only move to stay in the game would have
been to go back with the black king
black would have lost two whole Tempe
and uh actually here white has several
promising moves firstly attacking this
Knight which is pinned secondly if
necessary just pushing this Pawn forward
and the advance of this Pawn would have
given black an extremely difficult
defense instead we saw the Knight give a
check and this was a mistake due to the
really clever move King to F6 from a
niche this was the key defensive idea
because if Rook takes Knight black can
simply bring his Rook across pin the
White Knight and save the game we saw
later on the game did eventually fizzle
out to that draw
oh impressive uh resource there from
farrugia and uh quite hard spot we're
just seconds left and I'm also impressed
by Anish his instincts on finding these
very great moves
yeah I should point out in this final
position Rick H5 clings on to the night
but G6 is the one that clinches the
result Bishop b-8 I realized as I said
it for completeness sake Bishop B8 would
be a big blunder due to a Checkmate on
the board yeah unexpected things happens
of course beautiful saving by the way
yeah get responded all that and save the
game absolutely and they will be playing
their Armageddon game in approximately
four minutes
oh who do you think is the favorite
um alireza farooja he's had mixed
results in the Armageddon I think Anish
will will make it look at him the way
he's relaxed
and he's just in his chair
yeah is he tweeting is he I don't know I
was also wondering what is he doing and
probably he's just enjoying he's
preparing for the armaghetti look at
that Aha and uh he's not Wesley so so he
is chilling at the wrong board perhaps
he's Consulting his uh online trainer
or game review maybe he's texting wow
they're actually sitting at different
boards right now Anish sitting elsewhere
as you said Ivanka I didn't realize that
uh farage was actually ready to get
going Anish yeah maybe he's texting Owen
Lami uh his second here in Stavanger
back at the hotel asking him last minute
what tips he should try in the opening I
think alireza is still in the previous
game a bit do you think he got over on
that one
he's doing a Beth Harmon just trying to
find out what's happening on the ceiling
there
alareza ferrugia
and he's out of that now no more
calculation he needs to get in the
moment
things will be very fast once the clock
starts and I believe it's very difficult
sometimes to get out of the previous
game especially it was such a heavy
calculation so many ups and downs so
many things happening in the classical
game
even some opportunities which which you
just highlighted and of course your
brain is ticking and asking questions
why didn't I do this oh I had that
opportunity but it's already the time to
focus on the next game and go for the
Armageddon because alireza is in a must
win situation which is not going to be
so easy unless something very wrong goes
in the opening for Anish what happened
for example for him against Magnus
Carlsen he had such a bad opening that
after removed 12 he could resign
practically yeah he got himself
caught in an opening trap there but uh
we have to also mention that Anish giri
he is an opening theoretician you know
he's done how many courses
three quite a few accessible courses and
uh what I like about Anisha is he
practices what he preaches
at the last classical tournament that he
played he was just playing his course he
didn't care yeah yeah I love it also I
really like animation and the wrestling
and others they just yeah of course I
played this game I was giving the course
and of course that's that's what I
played that's why I gave it's a good
line
of course it's in the course
and uh here we go it's a handshake we're
off far Asia starting with E4 just as we
saw in the classical game between these
two and okay a repeat
so fast up to this point the players
replicating their classical encounter
who's going to be the first to Flinch
who's going to be blinking here and
deviating and actually it's a farugia
who plays the move H3 and we saw the
hesitation there from a niche similar to
it and might be three
now the question is should black take on
A3 he says yes and yes
so black Parts with the bishop for night
in return he gets a slightly better Pawn
structure White's a pawns do not make a
great impression but for Russia quick to
lock things down to close things because
he'll later try to strike on the king
side interesting decision I must say
playing C4 and giving away the D4 Square
Knight is going now towards to eight to
C5 with black knight H4 of course
eventually F4 wants to show up
yeah it will land sooner or later black
needs to be ready for that move first
big question does he allow the bishop
for Night Exchange in the center does he
uh kind of back up that night does he
just guard it simply lots of questions
and lightning fast from furosh up to
this point
asking big questions
C5 is something comes to mind at the
same time he would be not necessarily
happy that the B file is so open and
there are new weaknesses coming but it's
on the board
this on the board and it's about when
ferrugia can time this F4 break you
don't want to rush too soon because your
knight might be vulnerable on the edge
of the board to the black queen so how
do you finesse this it's not so easy
white is stuck for Pawn break stuck for
ideas other than pushing the spawn first
he puts his Rook on the second rank yeah
I did I wanted to say this because he
wants to go Queen E1 so Knight C2 is
taken away from with the Rook we need
one and F4 that's that can be the idea
nice guarding the night and should Anish
take inspiration from this move and also
move his Rook up to A7 oh no I like that
idea Ivanka I wanted to give you the
Rook exactly Queen does a move to E1
he's he's getting ready to line up G5
this is what I wanted to see
interesting because the White Knight
lacks squares only two squares you
cannot jump forward right now this
Square on F5 is covered twice you cannot
Retreat either because this Knight's
simply taken off the board and at the
very end of this black uh Bishop will
capture on H3 so he's basically forced
White's hand either white needs to
gamble and sacrifice all white needs to
capture the Knight on D4 but that's
strategically undesirable he has one
other move at his disposal which is to
go F4
yeah as I mentioned sacrificing the
night it's uh yeah definitely on the
cards he's gonna play it right that's
farusha that's his style that's in the
board
it's on the board and Anish a bit of a
frown a bit of a pause what do you think
Anisha is going to do take the Knight oh
any other options well first of all I
think it's a surprise for Anish which is
not a good thing for him
but today people would play F5 in this
position
might have been a possibility Judith and
oh
this is Bray from Anish he's just
happily capturing everything
any material offered to him he's taking
and now H4 games give that away yeah
you called it there was a big threat
White's Queen needed and wanted to take
this Pawn on G3 and look at this double
exclamation mark for anisha's move just
protecting everything not caring about
material
but you see people are not taking
exchange Bishop verse more than a rook
but wait one second this queen on E3 has
been awarded across it's a mistake
natural but that means a missed
opportunity maybe best was to Simply get
greedy best was maybe to take this black
rook and then take the bishop and hope
that the extra material for white there
would count but understandable that
farouza wants to keep the attack going
maybe there is a move Knight F6 with an
idea of Knight G4
wow that's very beautiful Judith Knight
F6 to G4 hoping to break through with
the black queen to H2 later on with a
checkmate
who's check meeting who that's the
question right now
because after Bishop G5 also in that G4
was kind of my plan
okay not F6 will that be what Anish
finds here
calculation definitely needed for that
one that's a king age okay but he moves
his Rook
who went mistakes everywhere now
question mark natural mistake uh not an
obvious one from Anish maybe that was
better but I think a very human move
there to get out of the way of that
Bishop saving the Rook yes and it would
be great for black if white eventually
takes on E6 then rookie 6 shows up again
and then Rook G6 so it seems like very
very stable for
black but of course it's not taken
engage seven yeah it has to get out the
way no discover checks allowed King's
safe for now
Black's still a piece up but the bishop
is going nowhere
what to do surely eventually it's gonna
be taken
get it off the board
you need to do that sooner or later I
don't think there's any other useful
moves here for white
you kind of need to get this bishop out
the way on G2 to swing the white Rook
across but it takes a long long time
now the question is Knight takes or Rook
takes
or pontics three possible cups I don't
trust the phone takes Rick takes plate
it makes a lot of sense because the Rook
is getting ready to
just play Rook to G6 and cover the G
line at the end the other Rook yeah and
the other Rook also comes so the
doubling on the G4 can be very powerful
and later stage
yeah there's a lot of targets on the G
file as well white has the two Bishops
queen king all stuck in the G file if a
black Rook lands lands there could be
game over could be decisive happens on
Rook F2 F6
now Rook F2 hits this Pawn
does black defend that I guess so
I'm also wondering about ignoring that
but uh yeah there are all sorts of night
folks in the air as well so uh White has
to be slightly careful in certain
variations
down 345
oh he's just defends his Bishop
that's met by F6 anyway Judith your idea
hitting the bishop next move Rook G8 is
on tap and uh is it Knight E2 also
something that alireza needs to consider
he's just happy to give up The Rook
because after that takes and Bishop H3
will be extremely powerful having the
bishop on F5 showing up uh-huh but I
Bishop E3 awarded a question mark So a
missed opportunity for
alireza or not the best move
yeah the question is now do you simply
bring your Rook across the most natural
move in the position attack the White
Queen or is there something even better
well 92 is also something to consider
now
he's in with that black knight it costs
white as Rook so exchange up now for
black
still the threat of bringing the Rook
across Rook G8 but now maybe bishop H3
anyway enough to Rook G8 Bishop G5 back
hmm nice tactics Bishop H3 heading some
pieces on this diagonal white can block
the G file with his own Bishop
getting sharp getting complicated
what to do here for ferrugia he needs to
win
I was thinking about like Rook F2 just
hitting the queen and trying to uh kind
of at least expel her from the white
position but black can just give some
checks I think black gives check on the
event specifically so after King gauge
to Rook G8 and there is uh well Queen H3
Queen G4 but it seems like White's Queen
has not enough space you'll move to the
on the board
and a nice point of yours that you will
block any Rook to G8 with Bishop G5
yeah this one getting so sharp right now
Richie it's the most natural move but
white will plug that g file with the
bishop no time to take it because this
Rook on pre and the thing is that after
Rook G8 Bishop G5 The Rook moves away
then Bishop G4 can be very unpleasant
and the green from E2 has to be
completely pushed away and then the
White Queen can go to F3 so the attack
can be very very dangerous for black
yeah it can easily be a mating attack if
the black queen is pushed away from me
too
is suddenly happening out of nowhere
this attack from farrugia okay rookie
ate the most natural move on the board
forces
for Asia's hand Bishop G5
and okay will he simply Retreat here
Anish giri his Rook is under Fire
needs to move it
nowhere else to go just rookie seven
will hold the game after Bishop what
else Bishop so there's a very nice idea
Bishop G for f takes G5 ah the accent G
takes F H4 maybe that's important I
think that's very important it takes
Queen G takes H4 at the very end the
black Rook will win the White Queen back
that's a 2-3 move variation but these
players have calculated it both of them
by now otherwise Bishop G4 might be a
winning tactic for white
crazy position and Anish giri has less
than two and a half minutes on the clock
alireza farouza he has much more time
it's starting with an extra three
minutes on five minutes and the players
do get an one second increment when they
pass move 40.
what else to do for Rouge is about to
lose his dark Square Bishop you have to
play a move like Bishop G4 or give a
check or take Black's Knight you have to
do something quick
yeah it seems so that the white has to
react with the Bishop from H3 Jack
Bishop D7 Bishop G4 as you said process
of elimination is one of these three
moves Bishop G4 check or take
what do we think he's gonna go for I
think Bishop D7 is quite the sensible
move and after GTX F uh F takes G5
Bishop G4 oh well he went for a
different move
Bishop on F5 check King h8
I have this same options available you
either have to take the Knight or you
have to go back with your Bishop
otherwise black is simply winning due to
the pin on the G file
you need to do something taking the
Knight eliminates the defender of this
F6 Pawn uh forcing black to at least
decide what to do there
also takes a higher clock is ticking
I think a niche is defended superbly up
to this point I've got to say
material up as well draw in hand
how to keep the pressure up
he's burning all his time he knows this
is the critical moment for Asia it's now
or never it's
something or nothing in this position
for white well there is an option to
play Queen H3 what do you think about
that
creative dude if Pawn takes Bishop then
there's a discovered attack on the black
king suddenly
but uh if you do moves like that isn't
it quite tempting to maybe sacrifice
material or even just retreat by the
queen H5 yeah Queen H5 seems to be quite
scary
but uh
yeah after Queen H5 Bishop G4
and then taking on D7 and
push H5 maybe in these kind of positions
I think the instinct is to keep it
simple so you go for something that
gives you maybe a slight Advantage but
that's just not massively complicated
and we see alireza deep in thought this
is a critical moment
you spent over one and a half minutes
now on this move he needs to speed up
now the clocks are leveling out around
two and a half minutes each still
slightly more for white here but I don't
see any moves other than yeah simply
taking this Knight I like your one dude
but yeah if the black queen can come
back to safety swoop back and defend her
King but actually the in the move before
I believe Bishop G4 was good because
after F takes G5 H takes G5 was an
option
wow maybe Rook G5 Queen H4 no white is
not winning but here also some something
went wrong for white
it feels that way just judging by the
body language the clock times
for Russia doesn't look confident and
far Asia actually with less time on the
clock than Anish giri
and he is still thinking he can't think
too long he still has to make
over 11 Moves In order to get that one
second increment and as we heard one
second is hardly enough to even make a
move on the board
okay he treats the bishop
so now the key moment for Anish does he
have to move his Queen if he moves his
Queen she's going to kick get kicked far
far away or does he play a bit flashy
here and take this white Bishop
we think he can get away with it Judith
he definitely takes the bishop
oh no he's reaching for the queen no
Queen there Anish we thought he could
take this bishop and trade F6
isn't he putting himself in danger Rook
takes F6 now
yeah looks tempting if Knight takes the
white Bishop will give a check to the
black king and that could be deadly
although black can block there maybe
with one of the Rooks
still super complicated and now it's
through it's down on the clock one
minute 20.
Queen is so far away but maybe it's
holding together
maybe it's possible but uh
yeah what to do with white right Rook F6
is an option but I think Bishop F6 uh is
not really because then black text and
Rook G7 he's taken the Knight
now which Bishop to capture Anish is
reaching for the dark squares Bishop
he's going to take on G5
I think that must be the move it has to
be the move otherwise Bishop takes F6
looks like a killer he retracted his
hand before eventually deciding to go
for it
and now the white light Squad Bishop
needs to move needs to make a decision
anesh is also under two minutes but but
firoza has only 50 seconds left so
something fills that it went wrong or he
does not see how to create the winning
chance black has a big threat of
actually taking the pawn on H4
that would win the game so many Targets
on the G file feels like white needs to
bring the bishop back to block that line
but still scary for white there that's
what I believe that he must do because
after that black and go gtxh4 Queen H4
but that leads to a Perpetual check it
seems Rook H7 Queen F6
Rook G7 I'm gonna draw will suit and
look at this 14 seconds for alireza and
the clock is ticking down he won't even
get any increment no and even then if he
manages to make it it's going to be a
one second increment it's not enough
Rook H7 and game over oh wow and each
blocks the tracks white can't take the
Rook The Rook is poisoned there's a pin
on the G file he's gonna lose on time
and oh he resigns instead and it is
Anish giri who wins the Armageddon match
and Nets one and a half points
well done to a niche he held his nerves
in a really difficult position there he
broke the streak of losing three
armageddons in a row and he takes that
extra half Point farooja came close but
no breakthrough in that attack he 'll
recover better for
frickle
feel like iraz's position was so
dangerous
it was very dangerous no doubt about it
but Anish is a great defender also yeah
and great calculator as well and I was
uh definitely the right move I think you
know by a niche to kind of get into
these complications and force alireza to
actually think and it was very much
unclear and in the fog
yeah who can blame anyone for losing
track
absolutely it was it was a very
interesting game and the in the
beginning in the after the opening it
seemed like white is taking over like
after Knight of Knight H4 he wanted to
go Knight F5
and starting from F4 it really got crazy
yeah it's been a crazy day though Crazy
Games there and yeah these are the
scores of the round yes it certainly has
been quite an eventful day I mean it
started off very quickly with Magnus
Carlson and Shakira mamijov agreeing and
easy well quick draw and then fighting
it out in Armageddon entertaining us all
in the process and in other news gukesh
well he's making an inroad into the
standings by defeating orientare in
their classical encounter to walk away
with three points and other key results
with Hikaru Nakamura losing to Abdul
sotorov in the Armageddon so only
getting one point and here are the
standings after eight rounds Fabiana
Carana he is at the top with 16 points
out of 24. Hikaru Nakamura on 13 and a
half points out of 24 and Luke who is
close behind and cash with 13 points so
one of the one of those two Fabiana
caruana Hikaru Nakamura they will be
crowned Norway chess winner that much is
clear because unfortunately can only
perhaps get a show of second place
but it's going to be exciting because
take a look at Friday's matchups It's
the final round and the well it's the
encounter we are all waiting for there
in the middle Hikaru Nakamura takes on
Fabiana caruana with the white pieces
who will win it will be everything to
play for well we can only find out
tomorrow in other encounters good cash
faces off with the black pieces against
Wesley so and did anything else catch
your fancy well obviously no question
about it that for playing for the first
place that's the game of tomorrow's day
but at the same time I'm also extremely
curious how go cash is going to be
handling Wesley so with the black colors
yeah your cash was arguably the player
of the round today winning in classical
winning in style today against Harry but
I think we'll be following that game
closely Nakamura he's got to come to the
board ready to fight he needs the win at
all costs tomorrow I think our eyes will
be glued to that match I cannot wait for
starters and uh well it's been a
surprising day hasn't it you know did we
expect Hikaru Nakamura who's been very
dominant in the Armageddon to lose his
game to Abdul sator of someone who's
been struggling
well I think the classical game is
always the big question and that was a
pretty balanced game and in the
Armageddon I think it was already
something that Nakamura was not
necessarily completely focused of course
he wanted to win there's no question
about it but uh it went he drowned very
fast and of course for for another back
it was something that he wanted to save
his image that he's a fighter and he
fights until the really very end and he
showed that he can beat the very best
yeah and thank you and that is all from
us today here at Norway chess and it
sets the stage very nicely for
tomorrow's final climactic round it's
gonna be awesome will it be Fabiano
caruana will it be Hikaru Nakamura who
is crowned Norway Champion well we will
find out and all that's left for me to
say is thank you very much everyone for
watching at home and see you tomorrow
tomorrow same time same place
foreign
[Music]